THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON ENERGY,
UTILITIES AND COMMUNICATIONS
WILL COME TO ORDER. THAT MEANS
YOU, SENATOR NEWMAN. I'M SORRY,
SIR. GOOD MORNING. WE'RE HOLDING
OUR COMMITTEE'S HEARING TODAY IN
Ó STREET BUILDING IN ROOM 1200.
WE WOULD ASK ALL MEMBERS TO
REPORT AS SOON AS POSSIBLE. I
WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME EVERYONE
TO THE SECOND HEARING OF THE
ASSEMBLY BILLS FOR THE COMMITTEE
FOR 2024. WE HAVE 11 BILLS ON
THE AGENDA TODAY. TWO HAVE BEEN
PUT ON CONSENT, FILE ITEM NINE
AB 2905 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOH
AND FILE ITEM 11 AB 3062 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAUER KHN.
BEFORE WE HEAR THE,
PRESENTATION, WE YET TO HAVE A
QUORUM. SO WE'RE GOING TO START
AS A SUBCOMMITTEE. I SEE WE HAVE
OUR FIRST AUTHOR HERE. WE HAVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARILLO. SO IF
HE'S PREPARED, YOU MAY START
WITH YOUR ITEM AB 2109. GOOD
MORNING, MR. CHAIR. AND MEMBERS,
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT, ASSEMBLY BILL 2109. I
AM HAPPY TO PRESENT THIS BILL, A
MEASURE THAT SEEKS TO TREAT
INDUSTRIAL PROCESS HEAT RECOVERY
AS AN ENERGY EFFICIENT
TECHNOLOGY AND WOULD THEREFORE
REMOVE THE PUNITIVE DEPARTING
LOW CHARGE. THE CALIFORNIA
CEMENT INDUSTRY MUST BE CARBON
NEUTRAL BY 2045, AND ONE LEVER
THAT CAN BE UTILIZED RIGHT NOW
TO ACHIEVE THAT GOAL IS
INDUSTRIAL PROCESS HEAT RECOVERY
. HOWEVER, THE DEPARTING LOW
CHARGE IS THE BIGGEST BARRIER TO
WHY THE INDUSTRY IS NOT ALREADY
UTILIZING THIS TECHNOLOGY UNDER
THEIR NORMAL COURSE OF BUSINESS,
CEMENT AND STEEL MANUFACTURERS
PRODUCE EXCESS HEAT THAT IS
CURRENTLY NOT BEING CAPTURED.
THIS MEASURE WILL ALLOW THESE
INDUSTRIES TO CAPTURE THIS HEAT
AND CREATE A CARBON FREE
ELECTRICITY WITHOUT BEING
PENALIZED. AND MY BILL
SPECIFICALLY STATES THAT THIS
ELECTRICITY CAN ONLY BE CONSUMED
ON SITE AND CANNOT EXCEED 25% OF
THE INSTALLING CUSTOMER'S PEAK
ELECTRICAL LOAD. THIS MEANS THAT
NONE OF THE ELECTRICITY
GENERATED WILL GO BACK TO THE
GRID. TODAY, THERE ARE ONLY
SEVEN CEMENT KILNS AND ONE STEEL
MANUFACTURER LEFT IN CALIFORNIA.
THIS BILL SEEKS TO HELP ENSURE
THESE INDUSTRIES AND THE JOBS
THEY PRODUCE FOR SO MANY, CAN
STAY IN THE GOLDEN STATE, AS WE
HAVE SEEN, FOUR CEMENT AND FOUR
STEEL FACILITIES CLOSED SINCE
2006. ADDITIONALLY, IN JUST AS
IMPORTANT AS IMPORTANT LOAD WILL
BE EAST OF TODAY'S ELECTRICAL
GRID THAT HAS EXPERIENCED ISSUES
IN RECENT YEARS, IN 2020 AND
2022, CALIFORNIA EXPERIENCED
SOME OF THE TOUGHEST TIMES FOR
OUR ELECTRIC GRID. IT'S BEEN
ESTIMATED, WHICH MY SPONSORS CAN
ELABORATE FURTHER ON, THAT THIS
MEASURE WILL ALLOW A TOTAL OF
45MW TO BE GENERATED THROUGH
INDUSTRIAL PROCESSES. RECOVERY
IN ALL CEMENT PLANTS IN
CALIFORNIA. THIS IS A 45
MEGAWATT OF ELECTRICITY THAT OUR
GRID IS BEING RELIEVED OF AND
CAN BE UTILIZED FOR OTHER
CONSUMERS, AS WE WITNESSED IN
2020 AND 2022. THE DEMAND IS
HERE. WITH ME TO TESTIFY TODAY
IS BRUCE MANGINI, REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA NEVADA CEMENT
ASSOCIATION AS YOUR PRIMARY
WITNESS WILL HAVE TWO MINUTES IN
SUPPORT. YOU MAY BEGIN, THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS, BRUCE
MAGNANI ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LARGE ENERGY
CONSUMERS ASSOCIATION AND THE
CALIFORNIA NEVADA CEMENT
ASSOCIATION, CO-SPONSORS OF THIS
LEGISLATION, THÀNH, IT AS THE
MEMBER SAID, THIS IS ONE LEVER
THAT CAN BE PULLED TO HELP LARGE
INDUSTRIES STAY IN CALIFORNIA
AND DECARBONIZE DIFFICULT TO
DECARBONIZE INDUSTRIES,
SPECIFICALLY CEMENT AND STEEL,
IT APPEARS THAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE
TO MANAGE TO ADDRESS THE
CONCERNS OF THOSE THAT REACHED
OUT TO US. SO I'M HERE TO ANSWER
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS IF YOU
HAVE THEM. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES. NO,
SIR. OKAY ALL RIGHT, IF WE HAVE
ANY TWOS, YOU CAN COME UP AT
THIS TIME. GOOD MORNING, JACOB
EVANS WITH SIERRA CLUB,
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, DEAN TALLEY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION. STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NOW WE'LL
MOVE TO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ARE THERE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION IN EITHER PRIMARY
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION? NO NO. IF
NOT JUST. ALL RIGHT. I'M JUST
MAKING SURE I WAS GOING TO GIVE
YOU TWO MINUTES. MR. CHAIR
MEMBERS. BETH OLASO, ON BEHALF
OF THE AGRICULTURAL ENERGY
CONSUMERS ASSOCIATION, I THINK
WE YOU KNOW, WE ARE CONCERNED
THAT THE AMENDMENTS IN THE
ASSEMBLY WOULD BASICALLY MAKE AG
ALL NONRESIDENTIAL OR SMALL
COMMERCIAL CUSTOMERS, WHICH
WOULD BE AG PAY FOR ANY COST
SHIFT OF THIS BILL. I THINK WE
HAVE AN AMENDMENT THAT IS GOING
TO BE TAKEN IN APPROPRIATIONS.
IF THAT IS THE CASE, WILL WE
REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION? BUT
THAT'S KIND OF WHERE WE ARE. THE
COST SHIFT TO AG IS THE BIG
CONCERN. SO I THINK WE CAN GET
THERE AND LOOK FORWARD TO
REMOVING OUR OPPOSITION IF THAT
AMENDMENT IS TAKEN IN
APPROPRIATE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES,
WISHING TO TESTIFY EITHER IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION HEARING?
SEEING NONE, WE'LL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE. ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS, SENATOR
BECKER? YES, I THANK THE AUTHOR.
I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING MY TEAM
HAS SPENT A LOT OF TIME WORKING
WITH THE CEMENT INDUSTRY AND
HAVE TALKED ABOUT THIS ISSUE NOW
FOR SEVERAL YEARS. SO I
APPRECIATE YOU TAKING THIS ON.
AND WHEN WE HAVE A QUORUM, I'LL
MOVE THE BILL. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, SIR. THANK YOU, VICE CHAIR
DALLY. SO I JUST WANT TO I LIKE
THE BILL, BUT I'M ALSO CONCERNED
ABOUT THE AG FOLKS. THAT. SO
YOU'RE GOING TO TAKE AMENDMENTS
THAT WILL SATISFY THEM IN A
PROCESS? I'M WILLING TO CONTINUE
THE CONVERSATION. YES. IF THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT HAS BEEN
EXPRESSED, WE'LL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THEM AND COMMIT TO
I'LL BE LAYING OFF THE BILL
UNTIL WE SEE THOSE AMENDMENTS. I
THINK THAT WE NEED TO BE
INCLUDING IT INCLUDED IN THERE.
SO APPRECIATE IT. THANKS. THANK
YOU SIR. SENATOR GROVE, THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. THANK YOU, I
AGAIN HAVE COMMENTS LIKE MY
COLLEAGUE FROM BIEBER THAT, YOU
KNOW, REPRESENTING THE TOP THREE
FOOD PRODUCING COUNTIES IN THE
WORLD, THE AG INDUSTRY WAS
OUTSTANDING FROM YOU. I
UNDERSTAND AND CORRECT ME IF I'M
WRONG THAT THEY WERE IN. THEN
THEY WERE OUT AND THEY WERE IN.
AND IT'S KIND OF GONE BACK AND
FORTH ON A SHIFT. AND SO I JUST
WANT CONFIRMATION AND A VERBAL
CONFIRMATION FROM YOU THAT YOU
ARE GOING TO PUT THEM BACK IN
THE BILL WITH AMENDMENTS AND
APPROPRIATIONS. I COMMIT TO
THAT. AGAIN. I NEED TO JUST SIT
DOWN WITH THEM AGAIN, SEE WHAT
THEIR CONCERNS ARE. BUT YEAH, WE
HAD THOSE INITIAL CONVERSATIONS.
WE WERE ABLE TO ADDRESS MOST OF
THEIR CONCERNS, BUT I COMMIT TO
DO THAT FROM NOW ON. YES. OKAY
THANK YOU SENATOR CIERTO. ALL
RIGHT ALL RIGHT. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HEARING.
SEEING NONE. SENATOR CARILLO
ASSEMBLYMAN, WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE? YES IN CLOSING, I JUST
WANT TO TOUCH ON SB 596, WHICH
IN 2021 REQUIRED A CEMENT
INDUSTRY TO BE CARBON NEUTRAL BY
2045. THIS MEASURE WAS PASSED
WITH INDUSTRY SUPPORT, INCLUDING
THE CALIFORNIA CEMENT
ASSOCIATION, AS YOU KNOW, ONE OF
THE SPONSORS OF THE BILL. AND
WITH THAT, I JUST RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A VOTE WHEN THE
APPROPRIATE TIME COMES IN. THANK
YOU. WE'RE STILL SHY OF A
QUORUM, SO AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME, WE'LL SEEK A MOTION FOR,
THANK YOU SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
FAIR ENOUGH. THANK YOU.
WE'RE TRYING TO GET A QUORUM.
YEAH OKAY. ALL RIGHT.
ALL.
THE. ALL.
RIGHT.
SO.
WE HAVE AN AUTHOR, WE HAVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PELLER PELLERIN,
YOU ARE HERE FOR 2765. YOU MAY
BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY.
FABULOUS GOOD MORNING. GOOD
MORNING. OKAY THANK YOU. CHAIR
AND MEMBERS, I ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE'S AMENDMENTS, WHICH
CLARIFY THAT THE CPUC CAN REPORT
VIOLATIONS ON AN AGGREGATED
BASIS BY COMPANY. IN 2021, THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED A REQUIREMENT
FOR THE CPUC TO REQUIRE
TELECOMMUNICATION SERVICE
PROVIDERS TO TAKE ACTION TO
ENSURE SERVICES BE MAINTAINED IN
THE EVENT OF AN EMERGENCY. IN
2022, THE MILL FIRE SWEPT ACROSS
SISKIYOU COUNTY, DESTROYING 118
STRUCTURES AND EVENTUALLY
LEADING TO THE DEATH OF TWO
INDIVIDUALS. THE FIRE
SUBSEQUENTLY RESULTED IN THE
LOSS OF COMMUNICATION LINES,
EQUIPMENT AND INFRASTRUCTURE
BELONGING TO A
TELECOMMUNICATIONS PROVIDER IN
THE AREA. THE ABILITY TO
COMMUNICATE IN THE EVENT OF AN
EMERGENCY CAN BE THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN LIFE AND DEATH. AB 2765
WILL REQUIRE THAT THE CPUC. S
ANNUAL ANNUAL REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE INCLUDES INFORMATION
ABOUT BACKUP POWER, RULE
VIOLATIONS, AND THE CPUC. S
ACTIONS TAKEN TO ADDRESS THOSE
VIOLATIONS. WITH THIS
INFORMATION, WE CAN BETTER HOLD
ACCOUNTABLE THOSE PROVIDERS WHO
ARE NOT COMPLYING WITH THEIR
POWER, RESILIENCY REQUIREMENTS
IN ORDER TO ENSURE ALL
CALIFORNIA CITIZENS CAN USE
PHONES DURING AN EMERGENCY. I'M
HOPING IN THE ROOM WITH ME TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. TODAY IS
IGNACIO HERNANDEZ, WHO IS
REPRESENTING THE UTILITY REFORM
NETWORK. AND HE'S RUNNING IN
YOU'RE THE BEST. BARELY MADE IT.
THANK YOU. IS HE YOUR PRIMARY
WITNESS IN SUPPORT? YES, INDEED.
MR. HERNANDEZ, YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS.
IGNACIO HERNANDEZ, ON BEHALF OF
THE UTILITY REFORM NETWORK, WE
ARE THE SPONSORS OF THIS MEASURE
, THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
DISCUSSION ABOUT HAVING BACKUP
POWER FOR TELECOMMUNICATION
SERVICES IN CALIFORNIA. THERE'S
BEEN LEGISLATION AND ACTION AT
THE CPUC, THE ONE COMPONENT THAT
WE THINK IS ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY
IS TO ENSURE THAT THERE IS BEING
REVIEW OF THE BACKUP POWER PLANS
AND THAT THEY'RE ACTUALLY BEING
CARRIED OUT. THERE IS
INFORMATION THAT THAT IS BEING
DONE NOW, BUT THAT INFORMATION
IS NOT AVAILABLE OR MADE PUBLIC.
SO WE ARE UNAWARE WHETHER OR NOT
THERE IS ACTUAL COMPLIANCE, THE
EXTENT AT WHICH THERE IS
COMPLIANCE, AND THE EXTENT TO
WHICH ANY REMEDIAL REMEDIAL
ACTION WAS TAKEN OR NEEDS TO BE
TAKEN. SO WE THINK THAT WITH
THESE REPORTS THAT ARE INCLUDED
IN THIS BILL, IT WOULD BE,
CRITICAL SO THAT WE CAN HAVE
CONFIDENCE THAT YOUR
CONSTITUENTS IN CALIFORNIANS CAN
FEEL SAFE, THAT THE BACKUP POWER
WILL BE THERE IN THE EVENT THAT
THEY NEED IT TO CONTINUE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS. SO FOR THOSE
REASONS, WE ASK FOR SUPPORT AND
AVAILABLE FOR ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU. ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES HERE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE? AB 2765. ALL
RIGHT. SEEING NONE OPPOSITION
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION SEEING
NONE. THEN I'M GOING TO BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. ANY
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WITH THE BILL?
WE'RE SHORT OF A QUORUM. SO AT
AN APPROPRIATE TIME, AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME, WE WILL
CONSIDER THAT MOTION. WHICH,
SENATOR RUSSO, YOU HAVE A
QUESTION? TWO MORE. TOO MANY.
ASSEMBLYMAN, WHAT YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR. AYE, VOTE WHEN IT'S
APPROPRIATE. OKAY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. APPRECIATE YOUR
PRESENTATION. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
HAVE A GREAT DAY.
NEXT UP, ASSEMBLY MEMBER PAPPIN.
ARE YOU PREPARED? ARE YOU
PREPARED? YES. WHEN YOU'RE
READY, YOU MAY PRESENT AB 1921.
GOOD MORNING, MR. CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS. AB 1921 IS A SIMPLE
BILL THAT WILL INCLUDE LINEAR
GENERATORS IN OUR
SPECIFICATIONS. SPECIFICALLY,
THE BILL UPDATES AND CLARIFIES
THE DEFINITION OF A RENEWABLE
ELECTRICAL GENERATION FACILITY
TO INCLUDE LINEAR GENERATORS
USING RPS ELIGIBLE GENERATORS
ARE CUTTING EDGE TECHNOLOGY THAT
OFFERS A TREMENDOUS OPPORTUNITY
TO HAVE RENEWABLE POWER. AT THE
FLIP OF A SWITCH, THEY CAN RUN
ON ANY NUMBER OF THE THING I
LOVE ABOUT THEM, ACTUALLY, IS
THEY CAN RUN ON ANY NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT FUELS, NOT UNLIKE FUEL
CELLS, WHICH ARE ALREADY
INCLUDED IN RPS. IF LINEAR
GENERATORS REMAIN EXCLUDED FROM
RPS, THE STATE WILL HAVE A
SORELY LACKING PORTFOLIO OF ON
DEMAND POWER. AS WE APPROACH OUR
24 2045 DEADLINE, AB 1921 WILL
ESTABLISH TECHNOLOGICAL PARITY
AND HELP MEET THE STATE'S
RENEWABLE ENERGY GOALS. HERE TO
TESTIFY WITH ME TODAY IS JULIA
LEVIN AND KENT LEE. JULIA LEVIN
IS WITH THE BIOENERGY
ASSOCIATION AND KENT LEE IS WITH
MAINSPRING. ALL RIGHT. YOUR TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES WILL HAVE TWO
MINUTES APIECE. GOOD MORNING,
MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. I'M HERE TO SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF THE LINEAR GENERATOR.
AS THE ASSEMBLYWOMAN SAID, IT'S
A UNIQUE TECHNOLOGY THAT CAN RUN
ON ANY OF THE RPS ELIGIBLE
FUELS. AND IT'S FUTURE PROOF SO
THAT IT CAN RUN ON HYDROGEN ONCE
THERE IS AN ESTABLISHED STANDARD
FOR HYDROGEN AS WELL, AND BE
ZERO EMISSION, AND IT'S NEAR
ZERO EMISSION WITH ANY BIOFUEL
AND ULTIMATELY NET NEGATIVE, AND
IT CAN AID IN REDUCING
GREENHOUSE GASES. AND IT'S VERY
CRUCIAL ROLE IN SPEED TO POWER
IN MANY TECHNOLOGIES. EXAMPLE,
DATA CENTERS AND INFRASTRUCTURE
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE, WHERE
THEY'RE BEING TOLD THAT THE
UTILITIES WILL TAKE YEARS TO GET
THEM POWER. THEY CAN DO WE CAN
DO PROJECTS AND GET POWER IN
UNDER A YEAR. AND THERE'S A
PRIME EXAMPLE RIGHT NOW CHARGING
100 TRUCKS A DAY AT THE PORT OF
LA, WHEN THEY HAD BEEN TOLD IT
WOULD TAKE FOUR YEARS TO GET
POWER, TO BE ABLE TO CHARGE THAT
MANY TRUCKS AT ONE TIME, 100
TRUCKS AT ONE TIME, 300 A DAY. I
STAND CORRECTED. SO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME, SIR. THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS. GOOD MORNING,
JULIA LEVIN ON BEHALF OF THE
BIOENERGY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA, WE HAVE ABOUT 100
MEMBERS IN CALIFORNIA, INCLUDING
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS, TRIBAL
MEMBERS, PRIVATE COMPANIES AND
OTHERS THAT ARE WORKING TO
CONVERT ORGANIC WASTE TO ENERGY
TO MEET THE STATE'S SHORT LIVED
CLIMATE, POLLUTANT REDUCTION,
WILDFIRE REDUCTION AND AIR
QUALITY LAWS. WHEN YOU CONVERT
ORGANIC WASTE TO BIOGAS,
BIOMETHANE OR HYDROGEN, BY FAR
THE MOST BENEFICIAL THING YOU
CAN DO WITH THOSE RENEWABLE
GASES IS THEN CONVERTED TO
ENERGY WITHOUT COMBUSTION. AND
THAT'S WHAT LINEAR GENERATORS
CAN DO. IT IS A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY TO CAPTURE BIOMASS
AND CONVERT IT TO RENEWABLE
GASES OR BIOGAS FROM LANDFILLS,
WASTEWATER TREATMENT FACILITIES,
ETC. AND CONVERT IT TO THE
CLEANEST POSSIBLE FORM OF
ENERGY, WHICH IS NON COMBUSTION
ELECTRICITY, AND THAT
ELECTRICITY CAN PROVIDE CLEAN
FERM POWER. ALSO INCREASING
ENERGY, RENEWABLE ENERGY
RELIABILITY. SO FOR CLIMATE
REASONS, AIR QUALITY REASONS AND
ENERGY RELIABILITY REASONS, WE
URGE THIS COMMITTEE TO PASS AB
1921. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF THIS MEASURE? YOU CAN COME
FORWARD AT THIS TIME SEEING
NONE. LET'S MOVE TO OPPOSITION.
ARE THERE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION OF AB 1921? SEEING
NONE. I'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. ANY QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS?
SENATOR CABALLERO, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, MR. CHAIR, I REALLY
LIKE THIS BILL, AND I'D LIKE TO
JOIN YOU AS A COAUTHOR. I'VE
DONE THAT VERY RARELY THIS YEAR,
FOR OBVIOUS REASONS, BUT I THINK
THIS IS REALLY IMPORTANT. I HAVE
A QUESTION IN REGARDS TO, THE,
LANGUAGE OF THE BILL AND THAT IT
IS LIMITED TO RPS ELIGIBLE
HYDROGEN. EXCUSE ME, LITTLE RPS
ELIGIBLE, HYDRO, I HAPPEN TO
HAVE A NUMBER OF LARGER HYDRO,
HYDRO FACILITY REYES, THAT HAVE
BEEN DEEMED NOT GREEN BECAUSE
THEY'RE TOO BIG, IT WAS A WAY
THE RPS SYSTEM WAS SET UP A
NUMBER OF YEARS AGO, AND I'M,
YOU KNOW, I'M, I'M I'M
PERSISTENT, IF NOTHING ELSE,
THEY WERE EXCLUDED BECAUSE IF
THEY WERE INCLUDED IN THE EPA
SYSTEM, WE WOULD HAVE MET OUR
CLIMATE GOALS WAY EARLY. AND IT
WAS A WAY TO EXCLUDE PG AND E
FROM THE CALCULATION TO FORCE
THEM TO DO OTHER THINGS, LIKE
WIND AND SOLAR. GREAT. EXCEPT
FOR THAT SAN FRANCISCO GETS TO
COUNT THEIR HYDRO AS PART OF THE
EPA SYSTEM, WHILE MODESTO AND
TURLOCK THAT ARE LOCATED IN MUCH
MORE CONSERVATIVE PARTS OF THE
STATE, HAVE BEEN EXCLUDED FROM
FROM UTILIZING THEIR POWER AS
PART OF THE EPA SYSTEM, WHAT
THAT HAS RESULTED IN IS BECAUSE
THEY AREN'T GREEN. THEY HAVE TO
BUILD SOLAR PANELS AND PRODUCE
ENERGY THAT THEY DON'T NEED
BECAUSE THEIR HYDRO PRODUCES
ENERGY. SO AS WE START TO BUILD
A NEW SYSTEM OF ACCOUNTABILITY,
I'D LIKE TO US TO CONSIDER THAT
HYDROPOWER IS GREEN POWER NO
MATTER WHO PRODUCES IT AND WHEN
IT'S PRODUCED, AND THAT THAT
SHOULD ALSO GO INTO THIS SYSTEM,
EVEN IF IT'S NOT PART OF THE
RPS, WE OUGHT TO BE COUNTING IT
AS PART OF THE SYSTEM AND ALLOW
IT TO BE UTILIZED AS THE ENERGY
THAT GETS THE SYSTEM STARTED AND
GOING. IT'S GREEN NO MATTER
WHAT. SO THAT'S JUST MY $0.02
WORTH, DO WITH IT WHAT YOU WILL,
BUT I, I THINK THIS IS A REALLY
GOOD BILL AND I'M GOING TO
SUPPORT IT TODAY. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU, SECRETARY, CAN WE,
ESTABLISH A QUORUM? BRADFORD.
BRADFORD. HERE. DALLY. DALLY.
HERE. ASHBY. BECKER BECKER.
HERE. CABALLERO. CABALLERO.
HERE. DODD DURAZZO. DURAZZO.
HERE. EGGMAN. EGGMAN. HERE
GONZALEZ. GROVE. GROVE. HERE.
LIMÓN MIN. NEWMAN. NEWMAN. HERE.
RUBIO CIERTO. CIERTO. HERE.
SKINNER. SKINNER. HERE STERN.
WILK. A QUORUM IS ESTABLISHED.
OKAY, IF YOU WANT TO RESPOND TO
THAT OR HAVE AN ANSWER. OKAY.
SENATOR BECKER, JUST A QUICK
COMMENT AS WELL. THANK YOU. I'VE
BEEN TALKING TO THE INDUSTRY ON
THIS, AND THIS IS AN EXCITING
TECHNOLOGY. AND I THINK THAT
THIS CLARIFICATION IS, WORTHY
AND IMPORTANT. SO THANK YOU.
YEAH ALL RIGHT. SENATOR I MEAN,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER, WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE? I'LL TAKE ANY TITLE,
THANK YOU. SENATOR CABALLERO,
HAPPY TO ADD YOU AS A COAUTHOR
TO RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THIS IS AMAZING TECHNOLOGY
AND, LINEAR GENERATORS, THEY CAN
TAKE ANY KIND OF FUEL. THEY'RE
DEFINITELY THE WAY TO GO.
APPRECIATE AN AYE VOTE. WE'RE
SEEKING A MOTION FOR DUE PASS.
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY. IT'S BEEN
MOVED BY VICE CHAIR DALI.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON AB 1921 Dð PASS AND RE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY BRADFORD A
BRADFORD. AYE. DALLI DALLI AYE.
ASHBY BECKER A BECKER. AYE.
CABALLERO. CABALLERO. AYE. DODD
DURAZO. DURAZO. AYE. EGGMAN.
GONZALEZ GROVE. GROVE. AYE.
LEMON. MIN NEWMAN. NEWMAN. AYE.
RUBIO. CIERTO SKINNER. SKINNER.
AYE. STERN WILK EIGHT. THAT
MEASURE IS ON CALL. WILL ALLOW
ABSENT MEMBERS TO ADD ON IT
LATER ON IN THE COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION.
HEY, MEMBERS, WE HAVE TWO ITEMS
ON CONSENT. IS THERE A MOTION
FOR THE CONSENT CALENDAR? SO
MOVED. IT'S BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR DALLI. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
BRADFORD. BRADFORD. AYE. DALLI
DALLI. AYE. ASHBY. BECKER
BECKER. AYE. CABALLERO.
CABALLERO. AYE. DODD. DURAZO
DURAZO. AYE. EGGMAN. GONZALEZ.
GROVE GROVE. AYE. LIMÓN. MIN.
NEWMAN NEWMAN. AYE. RUBIO.
CIERTO. SKINNER STERN. WILK 7 TO
0. THE MEASURE HAS SEVEN VOTES.
WE'LL LEAVE IT ON. CALL FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS TO ADD ON AT A
LATER TIME, WE'RE STILL WAITING
FOR AUTHORS, SO WE CAN GO BACK.
WE'VE HAD TESTIMONY AND
PRESENTATION ALREADY ON FILE
ITEM THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CARILLO 2109. IS THERE A MOTION
FOR THAT? SO IT'S BEEN MOVED BY
BY SENATOR NEWMAN. WE HAVE A DUE
PASS TO THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON 2109. AYE, AYE. DALLI
ASHBY. BECKER. BECKER. AYE
CABALLERO. CABALLERO. AYE. DODD.
DURAZO DURAZO. AYE. EGGMAN.
GONZALEZ GROVE. GROVE. AYE
GROVE. NOT VOTING. YES. LIMÓN.
MÀ IN. NEWMAN. NEWMAN. AYE.
RUBIO CIERTO. SKINNER. STERN
WILK 5 TO 0 FIVE ZERO. THAT
MEASURE HAS FIVE VOTES. WE'LL
LEAVE IT OPEN, PUT IT ON. CALL
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS TO ADD ON
ITEM SEVEN. FILE ITEM SEVEN.
FILE ITEM SEVEN. PELERIN.
PELERIN. ALL RIGHT. AND WE'LL
MOVE BACK TO FILE ITEM SEVEN AB
2765 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PELLERIN. IS THERE A MOTION FOR
THAT MEASURE? I WILL MOTION.
THERE IS A MOTION BY SENATOR
BECKER. WE WHAT DO WE HAVE HERE
TO DO? PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATE. WE HAVE DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS. THE AMENDMENT
STATES CLARIFY THAT THE PUC
SHALL REPORT ANY VIOLATIONS ON
AN AGGREGATED BASIS BY COMPANY
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON FILE ITEM SEVEN. BRADFORD
BRADFORD. AYE. DALLI. ASHBY.
BECKER BECKER. AYE. CABALLERO.
CABALLERO. AYE. DODD. DURAZO
DURAZO. AYE. EGGMAN. GONZALEZ
GROVE. GROVE. AYE. LIMÓN MIN.
NEWMAN. NEWMAN. AYE RUBIO.
CIERTO. SKINNER. STERN WILK 6 TO
0. THAT MEASURE HAS SIX VOTES.
WILL LEAVE. PUT THE MEASURE ON.
CALL FOR ABSENT MEMBERS TO ADD
ON AT A LATER TIME. I SEE WE
HAVE A AUTHOR. WE HAVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CALDERON. ARE YOU
PREPARED FOR YOUR PRESENTATION?
SO WE HAVE. WE HAVE HERE WE
HAVE, AB 2462.
YES. THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS, I WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR YOUR
WORK ON THIS BILL, AND I WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. ASSEMBLY BILL 2462
BUILDS UPON THE RECOMMENDATIONS
WITHIN THE CPUC. ANNUAL SB 695
REPORT. THE SB 695 REPORT
CURRENTLY REQUIRES THE CPUC TO
PUBLISH RECOMMENDATIONS FOR THE
NEXT YEAR TO LIMIT CALIFORNIA'S
IOU COST AND RATE INCREASES,
WHILE REMAINING CONSISTENT WITH
THE STATE'S ENERGY AND
ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS. THIS BILL
WOULD ADD RECOMMENDATIONS THAT
COULD BE ACHIEVED BEYOND A ONE
YEAR TIME FRAME, INCREASING THE
NUMBER OF MEASURES AN IOU COULD
IMPLEMENT. AB 2462 WOULD ALSO
REQUIRE THE REPORT TO FACTOR IN
CURRENT TRENDS AND THEIR IMPACT
ON ENERGY COSTS AND RATES. FOR
EXAMPLE, THE REPORT COULD
INCLUDE A COST BENEFIT ANALYSIS
ON INCREASED VEHICLE HOME AND
BUILDING ELECTRIFICATION. AB
2462 SEEKS TO IDENTIFY MORE WAYS
TO ALLEVIATE CALIFORNIA'S HIGH
UTILITY BILLS. THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVED UNANIMOUS SUPPORT THUS
FAR, AND THERE IS NO OPPOSITION,
AND I HAVE HERE WITH ME TO
TESTIFY AND SUPPORT LARA PARRA
FROM SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON.
THANK YOU. YOU MAY PROCEED. TWO
MINUTES. HI. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR
AND MEMBERS LARA PARR, ON BEHALF
OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON,
WE BELIEVE THIS IS A GOOD
MEASURE TO LOOK AT THE HOLISTIC
ENERGY TRANSITION HERE FOR
CUSTOMERS AND SEE THE OVERALL
CUSTOMER WALLET AS THEY START
TRANSITIONING AND
ELECTRIFICATION. WE BELIEVE AS
THOSE MEASURES START TAKING
PLACE, WE COULD SEE CUSTOMERS
SAVE ABOUT 10% BY 2030 AND 40%
BY 2045. BUT THIS REPORT THAT'S
ANNUALLY WRITTEN SHOULD INCLUDE
THOSE TYPE OF MEASURES TO BE
LOOKED AT. AND WE HOPE WE CAN
COUNT ON YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO AND ME TO
OR SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING,
VALERIE CHIRLA ALEJO'S, PACIFIC
GAS AND ELECTRIC COMPANY IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, KAYLA ROBINSON, ON BEHALF
OF THE BUILDING DECARBONIZATION
COALITION SUPPORT. THANKS.
ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT SEEING NONE DO WE
HAVE ANY OPPOSITION? SEEING NO
OPPOSITION. WE'LL BRING IT BACK.
DO WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS BY
MEMBERS OF A MOTION? WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE, YES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. THANK YOU. WHEN IT'S
APPROPRIATE, IT'S APPROPRIATE.
WOULD YOU, WHAT? WE HAVE A
MOTION. DO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. IS IT? DO PASS,
AS AMENDED, TO APPROPRIATIONS.
BRADFORD. DALLI. DALLI. AYE.
ASHBY BECKER. BECKER. AYE.
CABALLERO. CABALLERO. AYE DODD.
DURAZZO. DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN.
GONZALES GROVE. LIMÓN. MIN.
NEWMAN NEWMAN. AYE. RUBIO. SATO.
SKINNER STERN. WILK IT'S FIVE
ZERO. WE'LL LEAVE THAT BILL ON
CALL FOR WHEN MEMBERS COME BACK.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU, SENATOR.
ALL RIGHT. DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER.
SEEING NO MEMBERS, WE WILL WAIT
UNTIL SOMEBODY SHOWS UP.
WE WERE ORIGINALLY EXCITED ABOUT
. LIKE I WALK IN. WE DON'T HAVE.
SO MANY. MEMBER. WE'RE WAITING
ON YOU. WE HAVE AB 2083. HAVE AN
AUTHOR. WE'RE READY TO ROLL
WHEREVER YOU WANT TO GO. WE'LL
TAKE YOU IF YOU WANT TO SIT
DOWN. STAND UP. WE DON'T CARE. I
LIKE TO MAKE AN ENTRANCE. CHAIR.
DALI. SENATORS GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING. I WOULD LIKE TO
BEGIN BY THANKING THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS
BILL. I WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE'S AMENDMENTS DESCRIBED
IN THE ANALYSIS INDUSTRIAL
EMISSIONS MAKE UP 23% OF
CALIFORNIA'S GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS, WHICH IS THE SECOND
LARGEST SOURCE BEHIND
TRANSPORTATION THÀNH. WHILE THE
STATE CONTINUES TO BE A LEADER
IN TRANSITIONING FROM THE
COMBUSTION TO ZERO EMISSION
TECHNOLOGIES IN THE ELECTRICITY
AND TRANSPORTATION SECTORS,
INDUSTRIAL EMISSIONS HAVE
LARGELY REMAINED UNADDRESSED. AT
AB 2083 IS A KEY FIRST STEP FOR
CALIFORNIA TO MODERNIZE
INDUSTRIAL MANUFACTURING AND
PLAN FOR HOW THIS INDUSTRIAL
SECTOR WILL REDUCE ITS
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS WITH
THE COMMITTEE'S AMENDMENTS, THIS
BILL WOULD TASK THE CALIFORNIA
AIR RESOURCES BOARD AS A PART OF
THE NEXT UPDATE OF THEIR SCOPING
PLAN TO ASSESS THE KEY
STRATEGIES THE INDUSTRIAL
MANUFACTURING SECTOR CAN
UNDERTAKE TO CUT ITS EMISSIONS
IN LINE WITH CALIFORNIA'S
EXISTING CARBON NEUTRALITY
REQUIREMENTS. ADDITIONALLY, IT
WOULD REQUIRE THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION TO EVALUATE
THE POTENTIAL TO ELECTRIFY
CERTAIN INDUSTRIAL HEAT
PROCESSES AND REQUIRE CARB TO
INCORPORATE THAT EVALUATION INTO
ITS ASSESSMENT. DEVELOPING A
REPORT THAT ASSESSES BOTH THE
OPPORTUNITIES AND THE CHALLENGES
IN REDUCING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS IN THE INDUSTRIAL
SECTOR, WHILE STRENGTHEN OUR
INDUSTRY'S SUSTAINABILITY, WHILE
ALSO HELPING CALIFORNIA ACHIEVE
ITS CLIMATE GOALS WITHOUT A
STRATEGIC APPROACH TO
DECARBONIZING THE STATE'S
INDUSTRIAL SECTOR, WE WILL MISS
THE OPPORTUNITY TO THOUGHTFULLY
TRANSITION TO A MORE EFFICIENT
AND RESILIENT CARBON NEUTRAL
ECONOMY BY 2045. WITH ME TODAY
ARE MARK FENSTERMAKER ON BEHALF
OF EARTHJUSTICE AND CARLA
ROBINSON ON BEHALF OF
INDUSTRIOUS LABS. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. FIRST WITNESS,
TWO MINUTES. THANK YOU. AND GOOD
MORNING, MR. CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS, MARK FENSTERMAKER, ON
BEHALF OF EARTHJUSTICE, A PROUD
CO-SPONSOR OF AB 2083,
CALIFORNIA'S INDUSTRIAL SECTOR
IS A CRITICAL COMPONENT OF THE
STATE'S ECONOMY, BUT MANY
INDUSTRIAL PROCESSES RELY ON THE
COMBUSTION OF FOSSIL FUELS,
EMITTING CRITERIA, POLLUTANTS
AND REDUCING AIR QUALITY, AS
WELL AS CONTRIBUTING TO OUR
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS. THANKS
TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER MURATSUCHI AB
1279 FROM 2022, THE STATE HAS
SET A GOAL TO ACHIEVE ECONOMY
WIDE CARBON NEUTRALITY BY 2045
WITH AN 85% EMISSION REDUCTION
TARGET AS THE MAIN COMPONENT OF
HITTING THAT NEUTRALITY GOAL.
REDUCING EMISSIONS FROM THE
MANUFACTURING SECTOR WILL BE A
KEY COMPONENT IN ACHIEVING THESE
GOALS, AND AB 2083 IS GOING TO
HONE IN ON INDUSTRIES POTENTIAL
TO DO SO. THE BILL IS NOT
SETTING A NEW EMISSIONS
REDUCTION TARGET FOR THE
INDUSTRIAL SECTOR. AGAIN IT IS
SIMPLY AN ASSESSMENT. WE
APPRECIATE THE WORK BY THE
COMMITTEE TO FIND A YES AND
APPROACH THAT CONTINUES. CARB IN
THE LEAD WITH ITS SCOPING PLAN,
IDENTIFYING STRATEGIES ON
REDUCING GHGS, BUT ALSO TASKING
THE ENERGY COMMISSION WITH GOING
DEEP ON EXPLORING THE POTENTIAL
FOR ELECTRIFICATION SOLUTIONS TO
INDUSTRIAL EMISSIONS, AND THAT
THIS EVALUATION WILL NEST INTO
THE SCOPING PLAN. THE 2022
SCOPING PLAN PROVIDES AN INITIAL
OVERVIEW OF DECARBONIZATION
STRATEGIES, BUT ONLY DEDICATES
SEVERAL PAGES TO THIS IMPORTANT
SECTOR. IN THOSE FEW PAGES, THE
SCOPING PLAN HIGHLIGHTS THAT
REDUCING INDUSTRIAL EMISSIONS
WILL LARGELY RESULT FROM
DISPLACING FOSSIL GAS WITH
ELECTRICITY. TÊ BRINGING THE CÁC
INTO THE FOLD WILL ENSURE ENSURE
THERE IS A THOROUGH ANALYSIS OF
ELECTRIFICATION OPPORTUNITIES
FOR MANUFACTURING. BUT AS THE
ANALYSIS POINTS OUT, THE SCOPING
PLAN ALSO IDENTIFIES THAT
POTENTIAL COST AND TIME BARRIERS
EXIST TO REALIZING THE
ELECTRIFICATION. WE WANT TO SEE.
AND TACKLING THESE BARRIERS IS
AN IMPORTANT, CRITICAL PATHWAY
TO ELECTRIFICATION AND THESE
ELECTRIFICATION BENEFITS ARE NOT
ONLY FOR GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS BUT ALSO FOR NON
COMBUSTION. REDUCTIONS TO OUR
AIR QUALITY AND, CRITERIA
POLLUTANTS. WE KNOW INDUSTRY IS
VITAL PART OF CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY, PROVIDING MANY
WELL-PAYING JOBS. AND WE WANT
MANUFACTURING TO STAY IN AND
THRIVE IN OUR CARBON NEUTRAL
FUTURE. AND THAT IS WHY WE'RE
WORKING WITH MR. BERMAN ON THIS
BILL. WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP, AND WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE ON AB 2083.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. NEXT
WITNESS. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, CARLA ROBINSON, ON
BEHALF OF INDUSTRIOUS LABS, AN
ORGANIZATION LEADING EFFORTS TO
DECARBONIZE THE GLOBAL
INDUSTRIAL SECTOR BY 2045.
CURRENTLY, CALIFORNIA IS A
LEADER IN INDUSTRIAL
MANUFACTURING. CRITICALLY, WE
HAVE A HOST OF INDUSTRIES LIKE
FOOD MANUFACTURING, APPAREL
PRODUCTION, PAPER, GLASS AND
MORE. DESPITE THE IMPORTANT ROLE
THAT THIS SECTOR PLAYS FOR
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY, THE STATE
DOES NOT HAVE A ROBUST PLAN ON
HOW TO STRATEGICALLY DEPLOY ZERO
EMISSION TECHNOLOGIES IN LINE
WITH OUR CLIMATE GOALS. HAVING A
PLAN DEVELOPED BY THE BICARB AND
CEC TO FACTOR INTO THE STATE'S
SCOPING PLAN WILL BE CRITICAL TO
OFFER AN ENERGY FORWARD, REPORT
ON HOW TO DECARBONIZE THIS
SECTOR FROM INDUSTRIAL HEAT
PUMPS TO ELECTRIC OVENS AND
THERMAL STORAGE. THIS ANALYSIS
CAN HELP LAY OUT MANY ZERO
EMISSION TECHNOLOGIES THAT EXIST
TODAY TO ELIMINATE LOW HANGING
FRUIT EMISSIONS AND INDUSTRIAL
MANUFACTURING. THE SECTOR HAS AN
UNFAIR REPUTATION AS HARD TO
DECARBONIZE WHEN THE TRUTH IS,
WE JUST HAVEN'T INVESTED THE
TIME AND CREATIVE POLICY MAKING
THAT OTHER SECTORS HAVE
RECEIVED. THERE'S NO DOUBT WE
CAN MAKE PROGRESS, AND THIS
REPORT WILL HELP IDENTIFY
STRATEGIES TO TACKLE AND
OVERCOME BARRIERS ACROSS THIS
MULTIFACETED SECTOR, ULTIMATELY
STRENGTHENING CALIFORNIA'S
INDUSTRIES GLOBALLY AND BETTER
POSITIONING THE STATE FOR
SUSTAINED ECONOMIC GROWTH.
WITHOUT A STRATEGIC APPROACH TO
DECARBONIZING THE SECTOR CREATED
THROUGH AB 2083, WE WILL MISS AN
OPPORTUNITY THOUGHTFULLY
TRANSITION TO A MORE EFFICIENT
AND RESILIENT CARBON NEUTRAL
ECONOMY BY 2045. FOR THOSE
REASONS, RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AYE VOTE. THANKS. THANK YOU.
THOSE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT ME TWO'S GALLAGHER. NICE
OF YOU. HEAR ME? TO TESTIFYING
AS AN INDIVIDUAL. GOOD MORNING,
JACOB EVANS WITH SIERRA
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. OKAY. SEEING NO OTHER FOLKS
IN SUPPORT, LEAD WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. I SEE AT LEAST ONE.
GOOD MORNING. VICE CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, DEAN TALLEY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION. AB 2083
DIRECTS THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION TO DEVISE A STRATEGY
REDUCING INDUSTRIAL SECTOR
EMISSIONS BY 85% BELOW 1990
LEVELS BY 2045. OUR OBJECTIONS
TO THIS MEASURE STEM FROM THE
FACT THAT THE BILL MUDDIES THE
WATER AS TO WHO CONTROLS
EMISSIONS REGULATIONS,
GREENHOUSE GASES IN THE STATE,
WHICH HAS ALWAYS BEEN DONE
THROUGH CARB. IT THEN LAYERS
INTO IT A PATHWAY FOR INDUSTRY
TO REDUCE EMISSIONS IN A WAY
THAT IS NOT TECHNOLOGICALLY
NEUTRAL. IT ONLY CONSIDERS A
ZERO EMISSION OR 100%
ELECTRIFICATION STRATEGY FOR ALL
INDUSTRY PROCESSES AND PROVIDES
LITTLE, IF ANY, SUBSTANCE TO
COSTS ON INDUSTRY EMISSION ACTS,
ON RATES, OR EVEN TECHNOLOGICAL
FEASIBILITY FOR INDUSTRY TO
COMPLY. WHAT'S IMPORTANT ABOUT A
STATEWIDE STUDY OR AN ASSESSMENT
OR A REPORT IS TO HOLISTICALLY
GET ALL THE DATA THAT IS
REQUIRED AND IN THIS CASE,
CHOOSING ONE TECHNOLOGY IS NOT A
COMPLETE SOLUTION FOR THINGS
SUCH AS HYDROGEN FUELS THAT ARE
CONSTANTLY TOUTED BY FOLKS AS
BEING A SOLUTION FOR INDUSTRY OR
ENERGY EFFICIENCY TYPE PROGRAMS,
LIKE THE ONES THAT ARE UTILIZED
THROUGH PIP AND THROUGH INDIGO.
THOSE ARE TWO GRANT PROGRAMS
MADE AVAILABLE TO INDUSTRY AT
THE CEC, AND EVEN THINGS LIKE
CARBON CAPTURE, STORAGE AND CDR.
THESE ARE ALL TOOLS WE AS
INDUSTRY MUST UTILIZE. BUT THIS
REPORT LEFT ALL OF THAT OUT,
WHICH IS UNACCEPTABLE. IF WE
WANT TO TRULY EFFECTIVE
ASSESSMENT OF WHERE INDUSTRY
NEEDS TO BE AND HOW CALIFORNIA
WANTS TO ACCOMPLISH IT. NOW, I
WANT TO THANK THIS COMMITTEE AND
STAFF FOR THEIR GREAT WORK ON
THIS BILL. THE CONCERNS THAT WE
HAVE RAISED, THE COMPLEXITIES,
THE LACK OF OPTIONALITY FOR
INDUSTRY THAT THIS BILL PROVIDES
WERE WELL HEARD BY MEMBERS AND
STAFF AND APTLY ADDRESSED IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS. NOW, I
HAVEN'T SEEN THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS YET IN PRINT TODAY,
BUT FROM WHAT I UNDERSTAND, IT
MOVES THE BILL IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION AND CERTAINLY WARRANTS
A CONVERSATION WITH OUR
COALITION. BUT BUT PUTS THE BILL
IN A MUCH MORE WORKABLE PLACE
AND LIKELY GETS US TO NEUTRAL.
UNTIL WE CAN WORK THAT OUT, WE
REMAIN OPPOSED AND MUST ASK FOR
YOUR NO VOTE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND ATTENTION TO THIS
MATTER. ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO
COMMENT ON IN OPPOSITION? GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
MARTIN VENDIOLA ON BEHALF OF THE
COALITION OF CALIFORNIA UTILITY
EMPLOYEES, CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS, WE ARE WAITING FOR THE
AMENDMENTS IN PRINT. WE ARE ALSO
THINK THAT THANK THE AUTHOR AND
THE COMMITTEE FOR MOVING THIS
BILL IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION, AND
WE BELIEVE THIS WILL GET US TO A
NEUTRAL POSITION. THANK YOU.
MICHAEL BOCCADORO, ON BEHALF OF
THE AG ENERGY CONSUMERS
ASSOCIATION, REPRESENTING A
NUMBER OF FOOD PROCESSORS IN THE
STATE, ALIGN OUR COMMENTS WITH
CMTA. THANK YOU. CHAIR MEMBERS.
CARLOS GUTIERREZ HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA COTTON GIN AND
GROWERS ASSOCIATION AND THE
WESTERN AG PROCESSORS
ASSOCIATION. ALSO LOOKING
FORWARD TO REMOVING OUR
OPPOSITION ONCE WE SEE THE
AMENDMENTS IN PRINT. THANK YOU.
KATIE LITTLE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF FOOD PRODUCERS, ALIGN
OUR COMMENTS WITH CMTA. THANK
YOU. GEORGE QUINTA WITH THE
ALLMAN ALLIANCE ALSO ALIGN OUR
COMMENTS WITH THE CMTA. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING. TRICIA
GERINGER WITH AGRICULTURAL
COUNCIL OF CALIFORNIA ALSO
ALIGNING WITH CMTA. HOPE TO
REMOVE OPPOSITION. THANKS THANK
YOU. SEEING NO OTHER OPPOSITION
OR SUPPORT, WE WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. SENATOR
BECKER. FIRST, I APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR BRINGING THIS UP. I'D
LIKE TO BE ADDED AS A COAUTHOR
OF THIS BILL. WE MADE A LOT OF
PROGRESS REDUCING EMISSIONS IN
THE ELECTRICITY SECTOR. AND WE
HAVE A GOOD UNDERSTANDING, I
THINK, OF THE POLICIES, THAT,
THAT WE NEED TO DO TO REDUCE
EMISSIONS FROM BUILDINGS AND
TRANSPORTATION. WE HAVE TO DO
THEM. BUT I THINK WE HAVE A GOOD
UNDERSTANDING. IN CONTRAST, WE
MADE VERY LITTLE PROGRESS IN THE
INDUSTRIAL SECTOR, AND WE NEED
TO KNOW WHAT ARE THE BEST PATHS
FOR REDUCING EMISSIONS. AND THEN
WE NEED TO PUT SUPPORTIVE
POLICIES IN PLACE TO HELP
INDUSTRIES MAKE THAT TRANSITION.
SO YOU KNOW, THE I WOULD JUST
SAY TO THE OPPOSITION, YOU KNOW,
THE, THE REDUCTION OVER THE 20
YEARS IS NOT OPTIONAL. THE
QUESTION IS, HOW CAN WE DO IT?
AND WE CAN'T HELP YOU UNLESS WE
HAVE A BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF
WHAT ARE THE MOST IMPACTFUL AND
COST EFFECTIVE PATHS, SO THAT WE
CAN PRIORITIZE PUTTING POLICIES
IN PLACE, AND SUPPORTING THOSE
MOST PROMISING PATHWAYS. YOU
KNOW, I'M TRYING ONE THIS YEAR
ON INDUSTRIAL DECARBONIZATION,
ON SUPPORTING THE USE OF THERMAL
STORAGE POWERED BY BEHIND THE
METER, CHEAP RENEWABLE ENERGY, I
THIS BILL DOES NOT FOCUS JUST ON
ELECTRIFICATION, AS MY
UNDERSTANDING, IT CALLS FOR
ASSESSMENT OF ALL THE AVAILABLE
PATHWAYS FOR REDUCING EMISSIONS
WITH ELECTRIFICATION AS JUST ONE
PATHWAY. THAT'LL BE, I THINK,
HELPFUL IN SOME CASES. SO I
THINK THIS IS IMPORTANT. BILL.
AGAIN, I THINK IT'S GOING TO
HELP US FIGURE OUT WHAT ARE
THOSE PATHWAYS THAT CAN HELP,
REDUCE, INDUSTRIAL EMISSIONS.
AND, YOU KNOW, I ENCOURAGE YOU
TO CONTINUE TO WORK FORWARD
WITH, WITH FOLKS TO, TO GET THE
BEST OUTCOME. BUT I ENCOURAGE I
WANT TO SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. SEN. NEWMAN MORNING,
SENATOR. WE'RE NOT PICKING ON
YOU. WE JUST HAVEN'T BE SITTING
TOGETHER, THIS LITTLE CLUSTER
DANGEROUS, I, YOU KNOW, I
ACTUALLY I APPRECIATE KI¾M AND
OTHERS CONCERN ABOUT THE SORT OF
ASSIGNMENT OF JURISDICTION TO
CEC VERSUS CARB. THIS IS
TRADITIONALLY BEEN CARB'S, AREA
OF JURISDICTION. SO ARE YOU
WORKING WITH THEM? TO CONSIDER
THAT OR TO ACTUALLY APPLY THAT
AMENDMENT? YES. LET ME JUST JUMP
IN. I WANT TO BE QUICK AND I CAN
READ THE AMENDMENTS, PLEASE, TO
THE CHAIR HAS HERE. SO MAYBE
THAT'D BE HELPFUL. SO,
AMENDMENTS REASSIGN THE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR LEADING THIS
BILL'S INDUSTRIAL
DECARBONIZATION ASSESSMENT FROM
THE CEC TO CARB REQUIRES THE
ASSESSMENT TO BE COMPLETED AS
PART OF CARB'S NEXT UPDATE TO
THE SCOPING PLAN. DELETES THE
BILL'S WORKFORCE ASSESSMENT.
REQUIRES CARB TO INCORPORATE AND
EVALUATION FROM THE CEC OF THE
POTENTIAL TO ELECTRIFICATION
CERTAIN INDUSTRIAL HEAT
PROCESSES. AS PART OF THE
ASSESSMENT, AND PROVIDE AN
ANALYSIS OF THE POTENTIAL SECTOR
WIDE EMISSION REDUCTION THAT
WOULD RESULT FROM THE
ELECTRIFICATION REQUIRES CARB TO
WORK WITH THE CEC AND CPUC TO
INCORPORATE AN ESTIMATE OF THE
POTENTIAL LOAD GROWTH AND RATE
IMPACTS ASSOCIATED WITH A HIGH
ELECTRIFICATION SCENARIO FOR THE
INDUSTRIAL DECARBONIZATION INTO
THE ASSESSMENT OF YOU AGREEING
TO THOSE AMENDMENTS. YES. OKAY,
SO THERE YOU ARE. OKAY. THANK
YOU. I THINK THAT'S A GOOD
START, SO, YOU KNOW, CARB HAS
ACTUALLY, IN MY VIEW, DONE A
VERY GOOD JOB OVER TIME LOOKING
AT, SORT OF THE BIGGER PICTURE.
AND I THINK THAT'S A HELPFUL
AMENDMENT. SO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ANY. ARE YOU SENATOR
CABALLERO? THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
APPRECIATE YOU TAKING THE
AMENDMENT. I THINK IT'S, I THINK
IT'S GOING TO RESOLVE SOME OF
THE ISSUES. I WANT TO SECOND
WHAT MY COLLEAGUE HERE HAD TO
SAY ABOUT THE CMTA CONCERNS. AND
EVERYONE WHO WAS A. ME, TOO,
I'M. I'M VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
THAT. LET ME ASK YOU WHERE THE
85, BELOW 1990 LEVELS BY JANUARY
1ST, 2045 CAME FROM. I'M SORRY,
GIVE ME THAT QUESTION ONE MORE
TIME. YES. THERE THERE IS THERE
THERE IS A DATE HERE THAT'S USED
AND A PERCENTAGE. AND I'M
WONDERING WHERE THAT CAME FROM,
IT 85% BELOW 1990 LEVELS,
CORRECT? YEAH SO OUR CARBON
NEUTRALITY TARGET REQUIRES THAT
EMISSIONS BE REDUCED 85% BELOW
1990 LEVELS, AND SO WHAT OUR
BILL DOES IS ASK, CEC SLASH CARB
TO ASSESS INDUSTRIES ABILITY TO
MEET THAT 85% TARGET SO THAT WE
CAN UNDERSTAND WHAT ROLE THE
SECTOR WILL PLAY IN THE OVERALL
GOAL OF MEETING THAT TARGET.
OKAY. IN OTHER WORDS, IT'S
ALREADY A TARGET. YES. WE'VE SET
OKAY. YES. GOOD. THAT THAT WAS
MY THAT WAS MY ONLY QUESTION.
AND I'M GOING TO SUPPORT IT
TODAY. BUT IT REALLY DEPENDS ON
WHETHER, THE COALITION IF YOU
WILL, IS SATISFIED THAT THE
AMENDMENTS GO FAR ENOUGH BECAUSE
THIS IS REALLY CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT IN AGRICULTURE, AS YOU
HEARD, IT IS ONE OF THE LAST MAN
FACTURING SECTORS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT TO RURAL CALIFORNIA.
SO I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE NOT, SETTING UP SOMETHING
THAT'S SO UNREALISTIC THAT IT
BECOMES IMPOSSIBLE TO ACHIEVE,
DESPITE THE FACT THAT, DAIRY
DIGESTERS HAVE PROVEN TO BE
EXTREMELY SUCCESSFUL IN REDUCING
METHANE, AND THEY'RE THE ONLY
INDUSTRY Kò THAT WE, SUPPORT
THROUGH THE CAP AND TRADE IN
TERMS OF, WELL, THEY'RE THE ONLY
INDUSTRY THAT'S MET THEIR
NUMBERS. THERE'S STILL
CONTROVERSY, AND BILLS THAT KEEP
COMING FORWARD TO TRY TO GET RID
OF OUR, OUR COMMITMENT TO THE
DAIRY INDUSTRY MAKES NO SENSE.
AND SO IF WE'RE GOING TO LOOK AT
GOOD SCIENCE, WE OUGHT TO BE
LOOKING AT GOOD SCIENCE AND
MAKING SURE IT WORKS. AND WHEN
IT WORKS, AND WE OUGHT TO BE
SUPPORTIVE OF IT. AND SO I WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE TAKING
CARE OF THE INDUSTRIES THAT,
PRODUCE FOR US IN THE STATE. SO
I APPRECIATE THIS BILL MOVING
FORWARD. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS, SENATOR
EGGMAN? I'D JUST LIKE TO WEIGH
IN WITH MY WITH MY COLLEAGUE IN
THE AG AREA. I WAS I WAS HERE
WHEN WE DID SOME WORK TO TRY TO
GET THE MONEY FOR THE DAIRY
DIGESTERS, AND ALL OF A SUDDEN,
THAT'S A BAD THING. I MEAN, WE
ALL NEED TO EAT. WE NEED WE NEED
A THRIVING, ECONOMY. AND
AGRICULTURE IS ONE OF THE WAYS
AND SO I JUST WOULD BE IN
CONCURRENCE WITH WE NEED TO NOT
CONTINUE TO PUT ESPECIALLY THE
SMALLER FARMERS OUT OF BUSINESS
AND MAKING IT ALL GO TO THE
BIGGER GUYS WHO CAN AFFORD TO DO
EVERYTHING THAT WE ASK. SO
SOMETIMES WE JUST HAVE TO SAY
ENOUGH WITH I MEAN, WE ALL
APPRECIATE THE, THE GREEN AIR,
BUT WE ALSO APPRECIATE THE MILK
AND THE ABILITY TO EAT. THANK
YOU. OKAY, I KNOW I DO ICE
CREAM. DON'T FORGET YOUR. ANY
FURTHER COMMENTS? QUESTIONS BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. HEARING
SEEING NONE. ASSEMBLYMAN WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR. THANK YOU TO MY TO
SENATORS FOR ALL OF THEIR
COMMENTS AND FEEDBACK. AND I
COMPLETELY AGREE. THE WHOLE GOAL
HERE IS TO FIGURE OUT, YOU KNOW,
WHAT ARE THE EASIEST PATHWAYS.
AND I I'VE SAID THIS IN OTHER
COMMITTEES, MOST IMPORTANTLY
WHAT ARE THE OBSTACLES. AND THEN
WE AS GOVERNMENT NEED TO LOOK IN
THE MIRROR AND FIGURE OUT HOW
ARE WE GOING TO HELP, WHAT ARE
WE GOING TO YOU KNOW, WHAT
FINANCIAL INCENTIVES AND
ASSISTANCE ARE WE GOING TO
PROVIDE? WHAT POLICY CHANGES ARE
WE GOING TO MAKE TO HELP THE
INDUSTRY? HELP ALL OF US, SO
THAT'S WHAT THE GOAL OF THE BILL
IS. APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS,
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH
OPPOSITION, RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. I BELIEVE,
VICE CHAIR DALLEY READ ALL THE
AMENDMENTS. INDEED AGREED TO
THEM. AND THANK YOU. YES,
ABSOLUTELY. AND THANK YOU TO YOU
AND YOUR TEAM FOR THOSE. SO WE
HAVE A Dð PASS IS A MINUTE TO
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY. IS THERE
A MOTION FOR THIS? SO MOVED.
IT'S BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
ASHBY. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON
FILE ITEM TWO AS AB 2083.
BRADFORD. A BRADFORD A DALLEY
NO. DALLEY NO. ASHBY ASHBY. AYE.
BECKER. BECKER. AYE. CABALLERO
CABALLERO. AYE. DODD. DURAZZO.
DURAZZO AYE. EGGMAN. EGGMAN.
AYE. GONZALEZ. GROVE LEMON. MIN.
NEWMAN. NEWMAN AYE. RUBIO.
CIERTO. SKINNER. STERN WILK.
IT'S A BIG COMMITTEE. ALL RIGHT.
THAT BILL HAS SEVEN VOTES. ONE.
NO. WE'LL LEAVE THE MEASURE ON
CALL AND ALLOW ABSENT MEMBERS TO
ADD ON AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME.
THANK YOU, SENATOR. ASSEMBLYMAN
BERMAN, NEXT UP, WE HAVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCKENNA. THE MIC
. THAT'S THE ORDER IN WHICH SHE
ARRIVED. AND SHE HAS FILED ITEM
EIGHT AB 2780. WHEN YOU'RE
READY, YOU MAY BEGIN. GOOD
MORNING, MR. CHAIR. AND MEMBERS.
I WOULD LIKE TO START BY SAYING
THAT I ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS SINCE APRIL 2022.
DIFFERENT STATES HAVE CONTRACTED
TRANSPORTATION COMPANIES TO
TRANSPORT TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
VULNERABLE PERSONS, MOSTLY
MIGRANTS FROM COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR TO DESTINATIONS OUTSIDE OF
THEIR STATE BORDERS. SOMETIME
PRIOR, NOTICES TO LOCAL
AUTHORITIES OR NONPROFIT GROUPS
BEFORE DISCHARGING VULNERABLE
PASSENGERS ARE NOT PROVIDED, AND
OTHER TIMES THESE NOTICES ARE
INCONSISTENT, THEREBY
ENDANGERING THE PASSENGERS AND
OVERWHELMING LOCAL SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES. AB 2780 WILL REQUIRE
CARRIERS OF PASSENGERS PRIOR TO
TRANSPORTING TEN OR MORE
VULNERABLE PASSENGERS TO NOTIFY
LOCAL AUTHORITIES AND SEEK
AUTHORIZATION, AMONG AMONG OTHER
REQUIREMENTS. MOREOVER, IN ORDER
TO SEEK PREVENTATIVE RELIEF, THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL, A PERSON BEING
TRANSPORTED AND A PERSON FROM
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES PROVIDERS
MAY BRING CIVIL ACTION. IN
ADDITION, THE DUMPING OF
PASSENGERS WOULD RESULT IN
PENALTIES UP TO $10,000 FOR EACH
ACT OF TRANSPORTATION.
TRANSPORTING A PERSON THAT
RESULTS IN ONE OR MORE VIOLATION
OF THIS BILL HERE TO TESTIFY
TODAY IN SUPPORT IS CAITLIN
LOUGHNEY, DEPUTY LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE AND
CHRIS BACA, DIRECTOR OF
HUMANITARIAN RESPONSE AND
MIGRANT ASSISTANCE WITH THE
COALITION FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS. THANK YOU. THE TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES WILL HAVE TWO
MINUTES TO MAKE THEIR
PRESENTATION. YOU MAY BEGIN.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING. CHAIR
BRADFORD, VICE CHAIR, DOLLY AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS CAITLIN LOUGHNEY, DEPUTY
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR HERE ON
BEHALF OF INSURANCE COMMISSIONER
RICARDO LARA AND THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE.
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER LARA IS A
PROUD CO-SPONSOR OF THIS MEASURE
BECAUSE HE BELIEVES IN
CALIFORNIA'S ABILITY TO SOLVE
PROBLEMS. CALIFORNIA WELCOMES
MORE MIGRANTS AND ASYLUM SEEKERS
THAN ANY OTHER STATE. THERE'S
CURRENTLY A ROBUST NETWORK OF
PUBLIC NONPROFIT AND RELIGIOUS
ORGANIZATIONS WHO WORK TOGETHER
TO PROVIDE BASIC, SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES TO NEWLY ARRIVED
MIGRANTS. WE'RE TALKING WATER,
FOOD, CLOTHING, MEDICAL
SCREENINGS. WHEN VULNERABLE
PEOPLE ARRIVE IN CALIFORNIA,
CALIFORNIANS STEP UP. DESPITE
THE EFFORTS OF SOME TO USE
VULNERABLE PEOPLE AS POLITICAL
PAWNS. OUR QUESTION IS WHAT CAN
WE DO TO MAKE THE SITUATION A
BETTER SITUATION? IS THAT
CERTAIN OTHER STATES HAVE CHOSEN
TO MOVE THOUSANDS, TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF VULNERABLE PEOPLE
INTO CALIFORNIA. INCONSISTENT
NOTICE, AT BEST, IS PROVIDED BY
THESE ACTORS OR BY THE BUS
COMPANIES THAT DISCHARGE
VULNERABLE PASSENGERS AT
SEEMINGLY RANDOM LOCATIONS AT
ALL TIMES OF THE DAY AND NIGHT.
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES THEN
SCRAMBLED TO MEET THE BUSSES
BEFORE PASSENGERS ARE RELEASED
ONTO THE STREETS, ENDANGERING
THE PASSENGERS AND OVERWHELMING
LOCAL SUPPORTIVE SERVICES.
INSTEAD, AB 2780 WOULD REQUIRE
PRIOR NOTICE OF THE ANTICIPATED
DATE AND TIME OF ARRIVAL, AND
WOULD ALLOW LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
SET THE LOCATION WHERE THE
BUSSES CAN DROP OFF. PASSENGERS
LET US KNOW WHERE AND WHEN, AND
WE WILL DO THE REST. THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT PIECE OF LEGISLATION
TO ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA HAS
THE ABILITY TO WELCOME MIGRANTS
IN A HUMANE MANNER, WITH DIGNITY
AND RESPECT THAT ALL HUMANS
DESERVE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU. NEXT
WITNESS. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS CHRIS BACH
AND I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
HUMANITARIAN RESPONSE IN MIGRANT
ASSISTANCE AT THE COALITION FOR
HUMANE IMMIGRANT RIGHTS, OR
CHIRLA. AND I'M HERE TO TALK
ABOUT AB 2780, WHICH WOULD
REQUIRE BUS COMPANIES
TRANSPORTING MORE THAN TEN
INDIVIDUALS FOR EMERGENCY
SERVICES TO NOTIFY RECEIVING
CITIES WITH 24 HOUR NOTICE, LIKE
THE MEMBER MENTIONED IN 2022,
TEXAS BEGAN SENDING MIGRANT
BUSSES TO SANCTUARY CITIES,
NOTABLY CHICAGO IN NEW YORK AT
THE TIME, WE HAD CHIRLA FELT IT
WAS, INHUMANE TO USE NEARLY OUR
MIGRANTS TO PUSH ANTI-IMMIGRANT
NARRATIVES, IN AN ANTICIPATION
OF RECEIVING OUR OWN BUSSES, WE
HELPED ESTABLISH THE LOS ANGELES
WELCOMES COLLECTIVE. OUR
COLLECTIVE IS A COLLABORATION
COMPRISED OF CITY, COUNTY CLERGY
AND NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS. IN
JUNE 2023, CHIRLA AND THE
COLLECTIVE RECEIVED OUR FIRST
MIGRANT BUS FROM TEXAS AND HAVE
SINCE WELCOMED 39 BUSSES WITH 40
TO 50 INDIVIDUALS EACH. THESE
INCLUDE INFANTS, SENIORS,
PREGNANT WOMEN, INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES, AND FAMILIES. WHEN
YOU RECEIVE NOTICE THAT A BUS IS
COMING TO LOS ANGELES, WE WORK
TO SECURE A SITE TO SERVE AS A
WELCOME CENTER, COORDINATE FOOD
AND CLOTHING, MOBILIZE
VOLUNTEERS, COORDINATE MEDICAL
SCREENINGS, PRELIMINARY LEGAL
AND CASE MANAGEMENT SUPPORT, AS
WELL AS FAMILY REUNIFICATION.
AFTER 39 BUSSES, IT HAS BECOME
CLEAR THAT HAVING 24 HOUR NOTICE
IS THE BEST WAY TO ENSURE A WELL
COORDINATED AND TRAUMA INFORMED
RESPONSE. IN INSTANCES WHERE WE
HAVEN'T RECEIVED NOTIFICATION,
WE ARE UNABLE TO GUARANTEE THAT
EVERYONE IS ASSISTED, WHICH
POSES MANY RISKS. TO BEGIN,
INDIVIDUALS CAN END UP IN
UNHOUSED SITUATIONS AS MANY DO
NOT HAVE LOS ANGELES LISTED AS
THEIR FINAL DESTINATION, AND
MANY DO NOT HAVE THE MONEY OR
THE RESOURCES TO GET TO THE
FINAL DESTINATION. ADDITIONALLY,
THERE IS A RISK OF THEM FALLING
VICTIMS OF LABOR ABUSE OR SCAMS,
SUCH AS GETTING CHARGED FOR
SERVICES THAT ARE FREE BY LOCAL
PROVIDERS OR IN THE WORST OF
CASES, MAY BE VULNERABLE TO
HUMAN TRAFFICKING. AB 2780 WOULD
ENSURE WE HAVE SUFFICIENT TIME
TO COORDINATE SUPPORT FOR
MIGRANTS WHO HAVE ENDURED LONG
JOURNEYS IN SEARCH OF NEW LIFE
IN THE UNITED STATES, AND IS IN
ALIGNMENT WITH OUR VALUES AS A
STATE, ONE THAT IS INCLUSIVE OF
IMMIGRANTS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF THIS BILL AND
WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE COME
FORWARD AT THIS TIME? GOOD
MORNING. MY NAME IS CECILY,
EMERGENCY MIGRANT PROGRAM
MANAGER AT THE COALITION FOR
HUMANE IMMIGRANT RIGHTS AND
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT?
GOOD MORNING. MY NAME IS SUZUKI
FIGUEROA. I AM THE HUMANITARIAN
ASSISTANT AND I'M A STRONG
SUPPORT AT CHIRLA. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT, NOW LET'S MOVE TO
OPPOSITION WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. NOW IS YOUR TIME
HEARING AND SEEING NONE. I'LL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
ANY QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS?
SENATOR DURAZO, THANK YOU TO THE
AUTHOR, IT'S A SIMPLE BUT VERY
POWERFUL MESSAGE THAT NEEDS TO
BE SENT. THAT NO ONE WILL BE
SUBJECT TO EXPLOITATION AND
INHUMANE TREATMENT WITHIN OUR
BORDERS. SO I REALLY APPRECIATE
WHAT YOU'RE DOING. AND IT'S TOO
BAD ALSO THAT THIS KIND OF,
INHUMANE TREATMENT IS IN THE
MIDDLE IS BEING HAPPENING IN THE
MIDDLE OF A VERY ANTI-IMMIGRANT
NARRATIVE, SO WE NEED TO STOP
THE ANTI-IMMIGRANT NARRATIVE AND
STOP THIS KIND OF TREATMENT. SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND I MOVE
THE BILL. THANK YOU, SENATOR
EGGMAN. GOOD MORNING, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCKENNA. I APPRECIATE
YOUR ADDRESSING THIS. THIS ISSUE
. AND IT'S TERRIBLE THAT THIS
HAPPENS, BUT I GUESS I'M
CONFUSED ABOUT WHY WHY, WHY
WE'RE GIVING IT TO THE CPUC IF
THEY DON'T HAVE ANY ENFORCEMENT
OVER IT. SO CAN I. ONE OF MY
EXPERTS. WE PLAN ON TAKING
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS TO MOVE
THIS TO CIVIL CODE INSTEAD OF
PUC. PUC BECAUSE OF THAT PRECISE
REASON. AND WE'LL DO SOME
CLEANUP IN THE JUDICIARY. THIS
IS DOUBLE REFERRED. SO WE'LL DO
SOME SOME MORE CLEANUP TO MAKE
IT TIGHTER. ONCE WE GET OVER TO
JUDICIARY. OKAY. AND THEN MY
OTHER QUESTION IS HOW I MEAN, IF
THEY'RE COMING IN FROM SOMEWHERE
ELSE, HOW HOW DO WE REGULATE?
HOW DOES THE PUC AND THEN WHO'S
BRINGING SO THEN WHO WOULD BRING
THE CARRIERS THAT THE BUS. AND
WE'RE WORKING WITH THE WITH THE
CHARTER BUSSES AS WELL. THE
CARRIERS WILL BE THE ONES THAT
HAVE TO, GIVE THE NOTIFICATION,
OKAY. THIS IT'S MOVING TO THE
CIVIL CODE BECAUSE THERE'S A
CIVIL ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM. SO
A CASE CAN BE BROUGHT BY THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL OR SOMEONE WHO
IS ON ONE OF THE BUSSES AS A
CIVIL MATTER, NOT A CRIMINAL
ONE. AND IS THAT TO THE DRIVER
OF THE BUS OR TO THE COMPANY?
THE COMPANY, THE CHARTER BUS
COMPANY. OKAY. AND IF THAT
CHARTER IS CHARTERED IN TEXAS,
LET'S SAY, AND THEN COMING INTO
CALIFORNIA, HOW HOW IS THAT
ENFORCED IT JUST IF THEY GET
CAUGHT, THEN THEY'RE GOING TO
GET SUED. YEAH. AND HOW DO THEY
HOW DO THEY KNOW ABOUT
CALIFORNIA LAW. WELL THE CHARTER
BUT WE'RE GOING TO TIE WE'RE
GOING TO WORK ON I WOULD SAY
THAT, SENATOR, THAT WE'RE GOING
TO WORK ON TIGHTENING THOSE UP
IN, IN JUDICI BECAUSE WE DO HAVE
A COUPLE OF THINGS THAT NEEDS
TIGHTENED UP. OKAY. YEAH
BECAUSE, I MEAN, THIS IS A
TERRIBLE PROBLEM, THAT IT IS A
TERRIBLE PROBLEM. IT IS A
TERRIBLE PROBLEM. BUT I, I DON'T
I DON'T SEE THIS AS A SOLUTION.
BUT I'M INTERESTED LIKE I'LL BE
INTERESTED TO SEE WHAT IT COMES
TO THE FLOOR, BECAUSE IF, IF
IT'S JUST GOING TO BE THE EITHER
THE DRIVER OR THE, THE CHARTER
COMPANY WHO LIVES IN TEXAS, AND
HOW DO THEY KNOW ABOUT THE LAWS
HERE? AND HOW THEN DOES SOMEBODY
FIND OUT WHO THEY WERE IF THEY
DROPPED THEM OFF AND LEFT TO BE
ABLE TO BRING THE CIVIL CHARGES?
I GUESS THOSE ARE MY JUST THOSE
PRACTICAL, LIKE ON, ON THE
GROUND KIND OF QUESTIONS. SO
ABSOLUTELY. AND WE'LL HAVE THOSE
TIGHTENED UP BY THE TIME THE
TIME IT GETS TO THE FLOOR. YES,
MA'AM. OKAY. THANK YOU VICE
CHAIR DARLING. SO I'D LIKE TO
JUST MAYBE EXPAND ON A LITTLE
BIT OF WHAT THE SENATOR FROM
STOCKTON WAS TALKING ABOUT. SO
$10,000. FINE. FOR A COMPANY
THAT'S NOT USED TO DOING THIS.
SO THIS IS GOING TO BE THIS IS
GOING TO FALL ON THE COMPANY.
AND THEN WHAT ABOUT THE RIGHTS
OF THE PASSENGERS? THEY HAVE TO
GET THEIR INFORMATION TO FIND
OUT IF THEY'RE IMMIGRANTS ARE
NOT IMMIGRANTS, AND SOME OF THEM
COULD BE IMMIGRANTS. SOME OF
THEM COULD NOT BE IMMIGRANTS.
WHO HOW IS THAT ALL GOING TO GET
SORTED? THIS IS WE KNOW THAT
THESE BUSSES ARE DROPPING OFF
IMMIGRANTS. THEY'RE THEY'RE
DROPPING OFF BUSLOADS OF
IMMIGRANTS. AS ONE OF THE
WITNESSES STATED, 30 TO 40, AT A
TIME ARE COMING IN TO DIFFERENT
PARTS OF CALIFORNIA, AND WE KNOW
THAT THAT IS HAPPENING. SO THIS
IS NOT A CHARTER BUS THAT
SOMEONE GOES AND BUYS A TICKET
TO GET ON A BUS TO COME TO
CALIFORNIA. THESE ARE THE
CHARTER BUSSES TAKING IMMIGRANTS
THAT ARE ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS OR
THAT JUST CAME ALONG. I'M SORRY
IF I'VE USED THE WRONG,
UNDOCUMENTED FOLKS AND THEY'RE
BRINGING THEM OVER TO A
DIFFERENT STATES AND DROPPING
THEM OFF WITHOUT GIVING US ANY
NOTIFICATION, AND WE'RE SAYING
THAT THIS IS NOT A HUMANE WAY TO
DO BUSINESS, THAT CALIFORNIA,
WE'RE ACCEPTING, FOLKS, BUT
WE'RE JUST SAYING WE NEED
NOTIFICATION SO THAT WE CAN BE
PREPARED TO HAVE THEM. BUT WE
KNOW THAT THESE ARE NOT TICKET
BUYING PASSENGERS. ALL RIGHT.
WELL, I KNOW THIS IS GOING TO
JUDICI, AND I KNOW THAT THERE'S
INTERSTATE COMMERCE RULES THAT
WE HAVE THAT ARE, ARE, AND I
THINK THIS IS FIRST OF ALL, I
FIND IT REALLY FASCINATING THAT
OUR INSURANCE COMMISSIONERS
FOCUSED ON THIS INSTEAD OF
GETTING LOWER RATES FOR
INSURANCE IN CALIFORNIA. THAT'S
FIRST OFF, I THINK IS SOMETHING
THAT'S CONCERNING TO ME. SECOND
OF ALL, THIS BILL HAS A LOT OF,
I THINK, CONSTITUTIONAL ISSUES,
WHICH I HOPE WILL BE FLESHED
OUT. AND I LOOKED AT MY
COLLEAGUES IN THE ASSEMBLY AND
THE REPUBLICANS ARE ALL OVER THE
PLACE. THERE'S SOME VOTED YES,
SOME VOTED NO, SOME LAID OFF.
I'M GOING TO LAY OFF ON THE BILL
TODAY UNTIL WE SEE WHAT COMES
OUT OF, OF JUDICI. I THINK
THERE'S A LOT OF ISSUES WITH
THIS BILL ON WHO'S LIABLE FOR
WHAT ACTIONS AND HOW DO THEY
KNOW THEY'RE EVEN GOING TO BE
LIABLE FOR THOSE ACTIONS. I
THINK THAT'S NUMBER ONE. AND
THEN I THINK TWO,
CONSTITUTIONALITY OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE ON THE BUS,
HAVING TO FIND OUT THE
INFORMATION FROM THEM IS AN
ISSUE AS WELL. SO HOPEFULLY
THEY'LL FLUSH THOSE OUT, IN Dð
DISH AND WE'LL SEE IT WHEN IT
GETS, OUT OF THERE. SO YEAH.
AND, YOU KNOW, THE BILL IS
SEEKING TO INCREASE THE WELFARE
OF IMMIGRANT PEOPLE BEING
TRANSPORTED. THE PURPOSE
LANGUAGE ON NOTIFICATIONS TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS PROVIDED
DETAILED INFORMATION ON MAY,
OUTWEIGH THE BENEFITS OF
TRANSPORTING AND PROTECTING
VULNERABLE PERSONS. IT CAN HAVE
EFFECTS OUTSIDE CALIFORNIA
WHICH, WHICH WHICH ARE THESE
PROTECTIONS? AS THE HARVARD LAW
REVIEW DEEMED THE DORMANT
COMMERCE CLAUSE IS, FACTUALLY
NEUTRAL CONSTITUTIONAL
FRAMEWORK. THAT IS, IN TERMS OF
THIS DISCUSSED REGULATION MAY
EMPOWER STATES TO LEVERAGE THE
DORMANT CLAUSE TO ADVANCE OUR
VALUES. FURTHERMORE, IN THE
EVENT OF THE LAW BEING TESTED
WITH THE PIKE BALANCE TEST, THE
TEST MAY NOT BE JUDICIALLY
WORKABLE BECAUSE THE COURT
CANNOT MEANINGFULLY COMPARE OF
WEIGH ECONOMIC COSTS AGAINST
NON-ECONOMIC BENEFITS. AND SO
WE'RE GOING TO WORK ON THIS
BECAUSE WE KNOW THERE ARE SOME
CONSTITUTIONAL, REVIEW ON THIS.
AND SO WE'RE GOING TO WORK ON
THIS IN JUDICIAL. BUT I DO THINK
IT WILL HELP. WE DO HAVE TO
START WORKING ON THIS. AND I DO
THINK INSURANCE COMMISSIONERS
SHOULD LOOK AT THIS AS WELL. WE
COULD DO MORE THAN ONE THING IN
THIS STATE. WE DON'T WANT TO DO
WITH INSURANCE, THE HUMANE, THE
HUMANE WAY OF JUST DROPPING
PEOPLE OFF IN THE MIDDLE OF A
CITY WHERE ALL WORKING ON, LOTS
OF ISSUES WITH CHILDREN, WITH
WOMEN, AND SO WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT PEOPLE ARE SAFE NO
MATTER WHERE THEY CAME FROM. SO
WHEN WE DROP THEM IN CALIFORNIA,
WE WANT TO SEND A MESSAGE THAT
IN CALIFORNIA WE TREAT PEOPLE
LIKE HUMAN BEINGS. THAT IS THE
MESSAGE WE WANT TO SEND TO THE
REST OF THE COUNTRY. AND WE HOPE
THAT THE REST OF THE COUNTRY
ALSO WILL WILL START TO TREAT
PEOPLE LIKE HUMAN BEINGS. WE
CAN'T JUST TRANSPORT PEOPLE,
DROP THEM OFF. THE CITIES AND
COUNTIES DON'T KNOW IF THEY'RE
COMING. WE HAVE HUMAN
TRAFFICKING ISSUES HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WE DON'T
WANT TO SEE THAT HAPPEN TO
ANYONE, NO MATTER WHERE THEY'RE
FROM. I WELL, I JUST WANT TO SAY
I AGREE WITH ALL THOSE
STATEMENTS THAT, YES, THE
COUNTIES AND CITIES DON'T KNOW.
BUT WE'VE SAID TO THE WHOLE
UNITED STATES, COME HERE, WE ARE
WELCOMING YOU HERE. SO, I LIKE I
SAID AGAIN, I'LL BE INTERESTED
TO SEE HOW IT COMES OUT. YOU
JUST THERE'S LOTS OF, I THINK,
SOME CONCERNS AND WE'LL SEE WHAT
HAPPENS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
SENATOR CABALLERO. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR. LET ME JUST GIVE SOME
CONTEXT TO THIS, BECAUSE I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT AND I, IN FACT,
THAT IT'S GOING TO BE JUDICIOUS,
REALLY IMPORTANT. I SIT ON
JUDICIARY. AND SO WE'LL MAKE
SURE THAT A LOT OF THESE ISSUES
GET TAKEN CARE OF. THESE ARE
IMMIGRANTS THAT HAVE BEEN
ALLOWED TO COME INTO THIS
COUNTRY, BECAUSE THEY FIT A
CRITERIA. AND WHAT'S HAPPENING
IS THE IMMIGRATION SERVICES, AND
OR THE, AUTHORITIES FROM
WHEREVER THEY ARE ALLOWED IN,
WHETHER THAT BE TEXAS, ARIZONA,
NEW MEXICO OR EVEN IN CALIFORNIA
. THEY PUT THESE IMMIGRANTS THAT
HAVE BEEN ALLOWED ENTRANCE INTO
THE, CHARTER VEHICLES AND THEY
TAKE THEM TO CITIES TO START
THEIR THEIR, IMMIGRATION PROCESS
. AND MANY TIMES WHAT THEY DO IS
THEY LEAVE THEM IN THE MIDDLE OF
TOWN AT 2:00 IN THE MORNING,
WITHOUT ANY INFORMATION ABOUT
WHERE THEY ARE, WHO THEY SHOULD
LOOK UP, WHAT SERVICES ARE
AVAILABLE FOR THEM. MANY OF
THESE, ARE FAMILIES THAT HAVE
YOUNG CHILDREN, BABIES IN ARMS.
AND, AND SO THE QUESTION
BECOMES, HOW DO WE TREAT PEOPLE
ONCE OUR COUNTRY HAS ALLOWED
THEM IN TO PROCESS AN
APPLICATION, WHATEVER, WHATEVER
KIND OF APPLICATION IS, HOW ARE
THEY TREATED AND WHAT WHAT DO
OUR CITIES DO TO PREPARE
THEMSELVES? AND SO THIS IS A
REALLY IMPORTANT BILL. I HAD
NEVER THOUGHT ABOUT DEALING WITH
IT FROM THE TRANSPORTATION.
ANGLE, AND I THINK THE POINT
THAT THE SENATOR FROM STOCKTON
MADE IS REALLY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE, WHILE WE, WE WANT TO
GET A HANDLE ON WHO'S BRINGING
THEM AND LEAVING THEM OFF, WE
ALSO WANT TO KNOW, HOW DO WE HOW
DO WE DEAL WITH THEM? WHAT DO WE
DO WITH A BUSLOAD OF IMMIGRANTS
LEFT IN DOWNTOWN SAN DIEGO OR
DOWNTOWN LA OR OR WHEREVER IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT? AND SO
HAVING MORE EYES ON ON THE
SITUATION IS GOING TO BE
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT. AND WE DO
HAVE RESOURCES. WE'VE PUT OUT
RESOURCES, FOR SOME OF THE
ASYLUM SEEKERS AND OTHER
IMMIGRANTS THAT ARE COMING. SO I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOU TAKING
THIS ON. IT'S NOT AN EASY TASK
BECAUSE WE'RE TRYING TO THREAD A
NEEDLE HERE, AND, I IT GOING TO
JUDICIAL SHOULD START TO, KIND
OF, I THINK CLARIFY WHAT WHAT WE
WHERE IT SHOULD GO, WHO SHOULD
BE RESPONSIBLE AND HOW WHAT KIND
OF INFORMATION IS GOING TO BE
NECESSARY IN ORDER TO, TO KEEP
THIS IS NOT THIS IS NOT A BILL
TO KEEP IMMIGRANTS OUT. THIS IS
THEY'RE COMING NOW THAT THEY'RE
COMING. WHAT ARE WE GOING TO DO
AND HOW CAN WE PREPARE AND HOW
CAN WE INSIST THAT THAT THE
BUSSES THAT THE COMPANIES WHO
ARE SEPARATE FROM THE DRIVERS,
ARE RESPONSIVE TO OUR REQUEST,
WHICH IS THAT WE WANT WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN, BE
PREPARED FOR THESE SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE THIS AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING IT IN
JUDICIARY. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU, SENATOR ASHBY. YEAH,
THANKS. I, YOU KNOW, JUST
ASSOCIATE MY COMMENTS WITH
SENATOR CABALLERO. I WAS A
LITTLE CONFUSED AS TO WHY WE
WERE HEARING IT HERE, BUT I DO
SERVE ON JUDICIARY AND I THINK
THAT MAKES A LOT MORE SENSE. AND
I THINK THERE WILL BE SOME
CLARITY BROUGHT TO WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO ACHIEVE, WHICH IS
GOING TO BE REALLY FUN TO GET TO
WORK ON WITH YOU. SO LET'S SEE
WHAT WE CAN DO WHEN WE GET OVER
THERE. THANK YOU. SENATOR GROVE.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR, I HAD THE
SAME KIND OF COMMENTS THAT I OR
THAT MY COLLEAGUE FROM BIEBER
HAD, BUT THERE WERE A COUPLE
THAT I'D LIKE TO FOLLOW UP. AND
MY COLLEAGUE FOR STOCKTON,
AGAIN, I'M NOT SURE WHY ENERGY
IS LIKE, WE'RE HEARING THE BILL
HERE WHEN IT'S A CHARTER BUS.
OPERATOR, IMMIGRATION ISSUE, SO
THAT THAT MAY HAVE BEEN
CLARIFIED WHEN I WAS OVER IN
ANOTHER COMMITTEE IN
AGRICULTURE, I APOLOGIZE. I'M
DOING DOUBLE DUTY TODAY, BUT I
UNDERSTAND THAT IT'S MY
COLLEAGUE MENTIONED FROM BIEBER.
THAT'S A $10,000 FINE, BUT IT'S
$10,000 FOR EACH ACT, UP TO TEN
PEOPLE ON THE BUS. RIGHT. SO
POTENTIALLY IF THERE'S TEN
PEOPLE ON THE BUS, IT WOULD BE
$100,000 PENALTY BECAUSE IT'S
PER PERSON. CORRECT. SO IT'S PER
PERSON TO THE CHARTER BUS
OPERATORS THAT COULD BE THE
CHARTER BUS COMPANY. THE
COMPANY. YES. FROM FROM TEXAS,
WHEREVER THEY'RE COMING FROM.
YES. OR EVEN INSIDE OF
CALIFORNIA, I WOULD GUESS, YOU
KNOW, I DON'T KNOW, AND IT SAYS,
BUT THERE'S ALSO, IT SAYS, THE
IT'S PRESUMED IN THE BILL, BUT
THERE'S NO WRITTEN. THERE'S NO
WRITTEN PLACE IN THE BILL THAT
NEEDS TO BE TIGHTENED UP.
AGREED. WHEN IT GOES TO JEWISH,
OF THE ACKNOWLEDGMENT OF THE
LOCATION AND THE, TO DEMONSTRATE
COMPLIANCE AND THE
ACKNOWLEDGMENT THAT THE
INDIVIDUAL PERSON WANTS TO GO TO
THAT LOCATION. SO IF THEY'RE IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE DESERT IN
TEXAS, THEY GO, HEY, YOU WANT TO
GO TO SAN DIEGO? AND THEY'RE
LIKE, YES. AND THEY PUT THEM ON
A BUS TO COME TO SAN DIEGO. IT
DOESN'T SAY, IS THERE A FORM
THAT'S GOING TO BE CREATED, OR
CAN THEY JUST GET A SIGNED
DOCUMENT FROM STEVE WHO SAYS,
YES, I WANT TO COME TO SAN
DIEGO? OR DOES IT NEED TO BE IN
THEIR NATIVE LANGUAGE OR LIKE
WHAT'S WHAT'S THE PROCESS?
BECAUSE THE CHARTER BUS OPERATOR
OR THE CHARTER BUS COMPANY GO,
LOOK, I WAS PAID TO BRING THESE
PEOPLE HERE. THEY WERE, YOU
KNOW, IT. SO I GUESS THERE'S
LIKE A LOT OF IT'S LIKE VERY,
VERY BROAD, LIKE, I GUESS. SURE.
ANYBODY JUST CURIOUS. I'LL SAY.
YEAH, I THINK THAT'S A GOOD
POINT. I THINK IT DOES HAVE TO
BE, ROLLED OUT VERY
INTENTIONALLY BECAUSE SOMETIMES
PEOPLE ARE COERCED TO SIGN
THINGS THAT THEY DON'T KNOW
ABOUT, OUR OWN EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR WAS DOING AN INTAKE
ONCE, AND THE FAMILY EXPRESSED
THAT THEY WERE ABOUT TO PURCHASE
THEIR TICKET TO GET TO THE FINAL
DESTINATION IN THE EAST COAST
WHEN SOMEONE FROM THE COMPANY
ACTUALLY STOPPED AND WAS LIKE,
OH, NO, JUST GET ON THIS BUS
THAT IT'S FOR FREE. SO THEY THEY
FOUND THEMSELVES ON THE OPPOSITE
COAST, AND THEN WE AS THE LOCAL
NGOS ARE THE ONES THAT ARE THERE
TO HAVE TO, YOU KNOW, HELP THEM
GET TO THAT FINAL DESTINATION.
SO I THINK IT IS GOOD TO WRITE
IT IN THERE, BUT I THINK IT HAS
TO BE VERY INTENTIONAL,
ESPECIALLY WITH LANGUAGE ACCESS,
JUST BECAUSE WE CAN. WHERE IS
THAT AT IN THE BILL? WHERE DOES
THAT SAY THAT THAT THAT'S THE
PROCESS. NO NO I'M SAYING I'M
SAYING IF THE IF THAT'S A
SUGGESTION THAT'S MADE, IT WOULD
JUST HAVE TO BE VERY FLESHED OUT
AND INTENTIONAL JUST BECAUSE
THEN THEY COULD JUST GIVE THEM A
FORM TO SIGN, WHICH COULD
HAPPEN. THERE'S NO PROCESS IN
THE BILL. WE AGAIN, WHEN WE GET
TO JUDICIAL, WE'VE ALREADY TAKEN
AMENDMENTS HERE. AND THEN WHEN
WE KNOW WE HAVE TO WORK ON THE
BILL, TIGHTEN TO TIGHTEN UP THE
LANGUAGE A LITTLE BIT MORE ON
THIS BILL. SO BY THE TIME YOU
SEE IT ON THE FLOOR AGAIN,
SENATOR, YOU'LL SEE THE
AMENDMENTS FROM JUDICI WHEN WE
AND SO ARE YOU ASSUMING THAT THE
AMENDMENTS FROM JUDICIAL WILL
IDENTIFY THE RESPONSIBLE PARTY,
MAKE SURE IT DOESN'T VIOLATE
INTERSTATE COMMERCE CLAUSE, IS
NOT A VIOLATION OF THE
CONSTITUTION, AND THAT THE
RESPONSIBLE PARTY IS THE CHARTER
BUSSES THAT WE DO. IT DOES SAY
THAT WHO THE RESPONSIBLE PARTY
IS, IT'S THE CHARTER BUSSES. AND
THEN I GUESS, LIKE, LIKE IT WAS
JUST STATED THAT SOMEBODY IS
BUYING A TICKET TO GO TO THE
EAST COAST, AND THEN THEY FIND
THEMSELVES ON THE WEST COAST, I
AGREE WITH EVERYBODY THAT THAT'S
WHAT'S HAPPENING. THESE PEOPLE
DON'T HAVE THE TIME. DON'T EVEN
KNOW THAT THEY'RE WHERE THEY
ARE. WHEN THEY GET TO
CALIFORNIA. THEY'RE THEY'RE
BEING DUMPED ON THE BUS. THIS IS
WHY WE HAVE TO WE'RE FIGURING
OUT HOW TO TRY AND SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM BECAUSE THEY'RE BEING
DUMPED ON BUSSES AND THEY DON'T.
THEY ACTUALLY DON'T KNOW WHERE
THEY'RE GOING WHEN THEY GET TO
CALIFORNIA AT 2:00 IN THE
MORNING. THEY'RE HERE. NOBODY'S
HERE TO WAIT FOR THEM. AND THEY
DUMP SOMETIME DUMPED OFF OF THAT
BUS WITH NOWHERE TO GO, NOBODY
TO TALK WITH LANGUAGE BARRIERS,
THINGS LIKE THAT. AND SO WE WANT
TO TIGHTEN UP THE LANGUAGE SO
THAT WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT WE
DEFINE A DROP OFF SPACES FOR THE
CHARTER BUSSES TO SEE DROP OFF
SPACES. AND, BASICALLY DROP OFF
SPACES AND WHAT TIME THEY COULD
BE DROPPED OFF AND NOTIFICATION
24 HOURS BEFORE. SO IT ALSO SAYS
IN THE LANGUAGE THAT THE
RESPONSE PARTY, WHICH IS THE
DROP OFF SPACE OR WHATEVER THIS
PLACE IS IN CALIFORNIA, MUST
RESPOND IN BEFORE THE
EMBARKATION OF THOSE PASSENGERS
COMING HERE. SO IF THEY DON'T
SPAWN, DO THEY JUST STAY WHERE
THEY'RE AT, EVEN THOUGH THEY
WANT TO BE HERE OR I'M JUST, YOU
KNOW, CALIFORNIA PASSED LAWS TO
MAKE IT OPEN. LIKE MY COLLEAGUE
FROM MODESTO SAID, THEY'RE
COMING, THEY'RE COMING, THEY'RE
COMING. SO I GUESS MY QUESTION
IS, IS THAT, WELL, I'LL JUST
LOOK AT IT. I'M GOING TO LAY
OFF. I'LL WAIT UNTIL I GET TO
THE FLOOR. I'LL JOIN MY
COLLEAGUE FROM BIEBER. BUT I
JUST SEE A LOT OF PROBLEMS. SOME
THAT I'VE IDENTIFIED, SOME THAT
I HAVEN'T IDENTIFIED. WE HAVEN'T
HAD A TIME TO GO THROUGH IT ALL.
I MEAN, I HAVE, BUT I JUST AS
FAR AS LIKE THE COMMITTEE
HEARING AND STUFF, BUT THERE HAS
TO BE SOME. IS THERE A FORM?
DOES IT HAVE TO BE IN LANGUAGES
WHOSE RESPONSIBLE FOR THAT? THE
STATE AGENCY PUTTING THEM ON THE
CHARTER BUS OR THE STATE AGENCY?
YOU KNOW, IT'S NOT A STATE
AGENCY PUTTING THEM ON THE
CHARTER BUS AT ALL. IT'S WE
DON'T KNOW WHO'S PUTTING THEM ON
THE CHARTER BUS. ACTUALLY, IT'S
BEING IT'S A POLITICAL THIS IS A
POLITICAL MANEUVER. IF WE FIND
OUT AND THE CARTEL. BUT RIGHT
NOW, WE DON'T KNOW WHO PUT IT ON
PUTTING THEM ON THE CHARTER BUS
AT THIS POINT WE DON'T KNOW. SO
WE DON'T KNOW THAT PART. SO WHAT
WE'RE RESPONSIBLE, WHAT WE'RE
REACTING TO IS WHAT HAPPENS ONCE
THEY GET HERE. NOT WHO'S PUTTING
THEM ON THE BUS, BUT ONCE THEY
GET INTO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, WHAT HAPPENS TO THEM
? THEY'RE COMING AND BEING
DROPPED OFF AGAIN AT 2:00 IN THE
MORNING, 3:00 IN THE MORNING. SO
THINGS ARE AND BAD THINGS ARE
HAPPENING. WE KNOW THAT BAD
THINGS ARE HAPPENING TO THEM.
EXAMPLE LIKE, SEX TRAFFICKING.
WE KNOW THAT THESE THINGS ARE
HAPPENING AND SO WE ARE NOT WE
REALLY CAN'T. I WOULD SAY THAT
WE CAN'T, REGULATE WHAT'S GOING
TO HAPPEN. WHO'S PUTTING THEM ON
THE BUS. WE KNOW IT'S NOT
AGENCIES PUTTING THEM ON THE BUS
, SO WE DON'T KNOW WHO'S
ACTUALLY DOING IT. I MEAN, I
AGREE WITH YOU THAT THERE'S A
PROBLEM, ESPECIALLY WITH THE
YOUNG KIDS. I MEAN, THERE'S
400,000 KIDS ARE MISSING.
MISSING. NOBODY KNOWS WHERE
THEY'RE AT. ABSOLUTELY OKAY. SO
I, I GET IT, I UNDERSTAND I DO
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO AND
TRYING TO MAKE IT SAFER. I JUST
DON'T KNOW HOW YOU GET THERE. IF
THAT MAKES SENSE. BECAUSE LIKE I
SAID, IT SAYS THAT THEY HAVE TO
HAVE A DOCUMENT OR THEY HAVE TO
GET AGREEMENT. WELL, IS THAT A
VERBAL AGREEMENT IS THAT A
WRITTEN AGREEMENT? WELL, IS IT
THAT I DEFINITELY LOVE TO WORK
WITH YOU TOO, ON THOSE
AMENDMENTS, BECAUSE I KNOW HOW
PASSIONATE YOU ARE ON SOME OF
THESE SUBJECTS. AND SO WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
PROTECTING EVERYBODY, NO MATTER
WHERE THEY COME FROM. THAT IS
THE MESSAGE WE WANT TO SEND
ACROSS THE COUNTRY. IS THAT WE
WILL NOT ALLOW ANYONE TO COME
INTO THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
NOT BE TREATED HUMANELY. WE WILL
NOT ALLOW ANY CHILD TO COME IN
CALIFORNIA AND BE SEX
TRAFFICKED. WE ARE THIS IS WHAT
THIS THIS IS THE INTENT OF THIS
BILL. AND SO WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
ON TO JUDICI AND TIGHTEN UP THE
LANGUAGE SO THAT WE CAN GET TO
THE INTENT, BECAUSE THAT IS THE
INTENT. I APPRECIATE THAT
BECAUSE, I UNDERSTAND YOUR
INTENT, I DO, AND YOUR INTENT IS
VERY GOOD. I DO GET THAT 100. I
JUST HAD QUESTIONS ON LIKE, HOW
DO YOU MAKE IT WORK ON THE
GROUND IS WHERE I'M AT. I GUESS
THAT MAKES SENSE, IF THAT MAKES
SENSE. SO THANK YOU FOR
RESPONDING. I APPRECIATE YOU
THANK YOU. SENATOR. I JUST A
FINAL SENATOR ALSO. THANK YOU.
JUST A FINAL COMMENT, I
APPRECIATE THAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
DEAL WITH SOMETHING THAT'S JUST
BEEN CREATED BY OTHERS. WE DON'T
HAVE THE EXPERIENCE OF DOING
THIS, THEY'RE THE CLOSEST HAS
BEEN WHEN PATIENTS ARE TAKEN
ACROSS TOWN AND DUMPED
SOMEWHERE, AND IT'S JUST
TERRIBLE. WHAT DO YOU WHAT DO
YOU DO ABOUT THAT? HOW WE HAVE
TO MAKE PEOPLE TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY. AND SO THIS IS
SIMILAR WHERE THEY'RE BEING
TAKEN INTO THESE BUSSES AND JUST
LEFT OUT THERE, THERE IS NO LAW,
THERE'S NO WAY OF DEALING WITH
IT BECAUSE IT WAS NEVER AN
ISSUE. IT WAS JUST CREATED. SO
THIS PROCESS, A HUMANE PROCESS,
IS WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO RESPOND.
SO I APPRECIATE THAT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
ANY OTHER FURTHER QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS HERE, I TOO WANT TO
COMMEND THE AUTHOR FOR MOVING
THIS MEASURE FORWARD. BUT I HAVE
TO SCRATCH MY HEAD AND SAYING,
WHY IS IT IN YOUR ENERGY, AS
STATED, MUCH OF THE ISSUES THAT
ARE BEING ADDRESSED HERE HAVE TO
DO WITH PUBLIC SAFETY OR
TRANSPORTATION, BUT AND THAT'S
WHY WE AMENDED THE BILL TO
REMOVE THE PUC'S RESPONSIBILITY
FOR OVERSIGHT, BECAUSE WE JUST
SAW NO NEXUS HERE. SO SO THERE
IS STILL A LOT OF UNANSWERED
QUESTIONS. AGAIN, WE UNDERSTAND
WHAT THE INTENTIONS ARE, AND
THEY'RE WELL INTENDED AND SHOULD
BE SUPPORTED BY THIS LEGISLATIVE
BODY, BUT I STILL THINK WE NEED
TO HONE IT IN AS TO WHO'S
RESPONSIBLE, ON THAT NOTE, I
WILL ALLOW YOU TO CLOSE. AM I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR. AYE.
VOTE OKAY. WE HAVE A Dð PASS TO
BE AMENDED IN THE SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. IS THERE A
MOTION? SO MOVED. IT'S BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR CABALLERO.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON FILE
ITEM EIGHT AB 2780. BRADFORD
BRADFORD. AYE. DELI. DELI. NOT
VOTING. ASHBY. ASHBY. AYE.
BECKER BECKER. AYE. CABALLERO.
CABALLERO. AYE. DODD. GAROZZO
DURAZO. AYE. EGGMAN. EGGMAN. AYE
GONZALEZ. GROVE. GROVE NOT
VOTING. LIMÓN. MINH NEWMAN.
RUBIO. CIERTO SKINNER. STERN.
WILK. 6 TO 0. BILL HAS SIX
VOTES. WE'LL LEAVE IT ON. CALL
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. WE NEXT HAVE UP
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GALLAGHER, AB
2750. BRADFORD TOLD ME THAT
GALLAGHER WAS UP NEXT. HE'S
TAKING THEM IN ORDER THAT
THEY'RE HERE. SORRY. THAT'S WHAT
HE TOLD ME. UNLESS. WOULD YOU
WANT TO YIELD TO ASSEMBLYWOMAN?
THATTA BOY. ALL RIGHT, WE'LL
TAKE UP. TAKE UP AB 2697. I
THINK THE SENATOR WANTED TO BE
HERE FOR YOUR BILL, BUT I. I'M
NOT SURE. MAYBE TODAY IS YOUR
LUCKY DAY. MAYBE TODAY IS MY
LUCKY DAY, GOOD MORNING, VICE
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. I'M
PRESENTING AB 2697, A BILL THAT
IS NEEDED TO IMPROVE THE EV
CHARGING EXPERIENCE. I WILL BE
ACCEPTING ALL THE COMMITTEE'S
AMENDMENTS AS AN EV DRIVER. I
HAVE BEEN FRUSTRATED WITH THE
ALL TOO COMMON EXPERIENCE OF
TRYING AND FAILING TO FIND A
FUNCTIONING PUBLIC CHARGER. IF
WE'RE SERIOUS ABOUT SERIOUS
ABOUT HITTING OUR EV AND CLIMATE
GOALS, WE NEED TO MAKE IT EASIER
TO FIND EV CHARGERS. THIS BILL
REQUIRES THAT PUBLICLY AVAILABLE
CHARGERS BE SUBJECT TO ROAMING
AGREEMENTS, SO THAT DRIVERS CAN
EASILY LOCATE AND ACCESS ACCESS
A WORKING EV CHARGER, REGARDLESS
OF WHAT COMPANY OPERATES IT.
WITH THE AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN
COMMITTEE TODAY, FCA,
CHARGEPOINT AND ELECTRIFY
AMERICA HAVE REMOVED THEIR
OPPOSITION, WITH ME TO TESTIFY
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL IS
ALEXIA, MELENDEZ MARTINEAU, WITH
PLUG IN AMERICA. OKAY. FIRST
WITNESS IS THAT YOUR ONLY
WITNESS? WE HAVE A COUPLE
MINUTES. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE TODAY. MY
NAME IS ALEXIA MELENDEZ
MARTINEAU. I'M PLEASED TO BE
HERE ON BEHALF OF PLUG IN
AMERICA, A NATIONAL NONPROFIT
FOUNDED BY EV DRIVERS AND HERE
IN CALIFORNIA WITH A MISSION TO
ACCELERATE THE TRANSITION TO
ELECTRIC VEHICLES AND CHARGING.
WE'RE HERE TODAY TO SUPPORT AB
2697, WHICH WILL IMPROVE THE EV
CHARGING EXPERIENCE FOR DRIVERS.
PLUG IN AMERICA CAN CONDUCT AN
ANNUAL EV DRIVER SURVEY, AND
BASED ON THE RESULTS FROM OUR
2023 SURVEY AND EARLY INSIGHTS
FROM THIS YEAR'S CALIFORNIA
SURVEY, PUBLIC EV CHARGING IS
CURRENTLY UNRELIABLE AND HAS
LEFT CONSUMERS WANTING MORE.
ACCESS TO CHARGING IS ONE OF THE
BIGGEST CONSIDERATIONS FOR
CONSUMERS WHEN TRANSITIONING TO
AN ELECTRIC VEHICLE. CURRENTLY,
AS AN EV DRIVER, WHICH I AM
MYSELF, THERE IS A HIGH
EXPECTATION OF YOUR ABILITY AND
WILLINGNESS TO ADAPT TO THE
CURRENT EV ECOSYSTEM. THIS CAN
OFTEN MEAN HAVING TO SPEND
SEVERAL MINUTES EACH TIME YOU
CHARGE ON A NEW NETWORK.
DOWNLOADING AND SETTING UP AN
ACCOUNT ON AN APP TO CHARGE,
ESPECIALLY AS CALIFORNIA EMBARKS
ON MASS MARKET ADOPTION OF EVS,
WE MUST MAKE THE CHARGING
EXPERIENCE MORE USER FRIENDLY TO
REDUCE BARRIERS TO CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION. ROAMING
AGREEMENTS HELP SIMPLIFY THE
CHARGING EXPERIENCE FOR
CONSUMERS BY ALLOWING THEM TO
USE THEIR FAVORITE APP FOR OTHER
CHARGING NETWORKS. THIS CAN
EMPOWER DRIVERS TO CHOOSE THEIR
PREFERRED PLATFORM, AND CREATES
COMPETITION AMONGST COMPANIES TO
PROVIDE THE BEST POSSIBLE USER
EXPERIENCE. THROUGH PURSUING
ROAMING AGREEMENTS FOR EV
CHARGING, AB 2697 CAN HELP MAKE
THE PUBLIC CHARGING EXPERIENCE
SEAMLESS FOR EV DRIVERS. THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WITH YOU TODAY IN SUPPORT
OF AB 2697. OKAY. WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
MICHELLE CARNALIS, UNION OF
CONCERNED SCIENTISTS AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ANY OTHERS
IN SUPPORT? A LITTLE BIT OF A
TWEENER, MEGAN MICKELBERG, ON
BEHALF OF THE EV CHARGING
ASSOCIATION, AVCA, I JUST WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR HER WORK
WITH US, AND WE'RE GOING
NEUTRAL. THANK YOU. HI. MEGAN
MURRAY, ON BEHALF OF ELECTRIFY
AMERICA, WE REALLY APPRECIATE
THE AUTHORS WORK AND THE
COMMITTEE'S WORK ON THIS BILL.
WE DID HAVE AN OPPOSED POSITION.
WE'VE MOVED TO NEUTRAL. WE JUST
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE AND THE AUTHOR ON
ROAMING AND KIND OF WHAT THAT
MEANS FOR FOLKS, BUT HAPPY THAT
THE BILL IS MOVING IN A GREAT
DIRECTION. THANKS SO MUCH. THANK
YOU. ANY MORE IN SUPPORT IN
BETWEEN? HOW ABOUT OPPOSITION?
YOU GOT TWO MINUTES. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS. CORY
BULLIS ON BEHALF OF FELLOW EV
CHARGING WITH AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION ON AB 2697. WE
HAVE WE'RE HAVING VERY
PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE AUTHOR AND HOPE TO CONTINUE
THAT. WE HOPE TO BE ABLE TO MOVE
TO A SUPPORT POSITION. BUT AS OF
TODAY, HAVE SOME REMAINING
UNRESOLVED CONCERNS. IN SHORT, A
ROAMING AGREEMENT IS A TYPE OF
CONTRACT. IT'S A TYPE OF
BUSINESS RELATIONSHIP OF WHICH
THE DETAILS ARE NEGOTIATED
BETWEEN TWO COMPANIES THAT ARE
COMMITTED TO IMPROVING THE EV
CHARGING EXPERIENCE. WE OFTEN
CUSTOMIZE THESE AGREEMENTS
BETWEEN EACH OTHER TO BETTER
SUPPORT OUR RESPECTIVE CUSTOMERS
AS THEY ROAM BETWEEN NETWORKS.
AB 2697 WOULD GIVE THE ENERGY
COMMISSION THE AUTHORITY TO
REQUIRE ROAMING AGREEMENTS, BUT
IT DOES NOT PROVIDE SUFFICIENT
GUARDRAILS THAT RESPECT THESE
BUSINESS TO BUSINESS
RELATIONSHIPS, INCLUDING HOW WE
OPERATIONALIZE THE CONTRACTS AND
THE MODEL THAT WE USE TO ROAM
WITH WITH ONE ANOTHER. THE
RESULTING EFFECT COULD BE THAT
THE COMMISSION GETS TO PICK
WINNERS AND LOSERS, INCLUDING
THE BUSINESS MODEL USED FOR US
TO ROAM WITH ONE ANOTHER. THIS
COULD HAMSTRING INNOVATIVE
APPROACHES THAT HELP IMPROVE THE
EV CHARGING EXPERIENCE, WHICH WE
OF COURSE SHARE THAT GOAL WITH
THE AUTHOR AND ULTIMATELY, IT
COULD PASS ON COSTS TO EV
DRIVERS THAT THEY DO NOT HAVE TO
BEAR TODAY. SO FOR THESE
REASONS, WE'RE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED AS OF NOW. LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR TO RESOLVE THESE
CONCERNS. THANK YOU. NEXT
WITNESS. THANK YOU. MICHAEL
DAFT, GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
MANAGER, GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
MANAGER. WITH BLINK CHARGING, WE
ALIGN OURSELVES WITH THE
COMMENTS MADE BY FLO AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING THE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE AUTHOR.
THEY'VE BEEN VERY PRODUCTIVE SO
FAR AND THANK YOU TO YOU AND
THANK YOU TO THE COMMITTEE AS
WELL. ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO ADD
ON AS A ME TOO. IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
CHRIS SCROGGIN WITH THE PRANK
COMPANY ON BEHALF OF
CHARGEPOINT. AS THE AUTHOR
STATED, WE HAVE REMOVED OUR
OPPOSITION IN LIGHT OF THE
AMENDMENTS. WANT TO THANK THE
CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE AND THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR WORK
ON THIS? AND OF COURSE, IF THERE
ARE ANY AMENDMENTS IN THE
FUTURE, WE DO RESERVE OUR RIGHT
TO CHANGE OUR POSITION, BUT ARE
GRATEFUL FOR THIS AND HAVE
REMOVED OUR OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU. SEEING NO ONE
ELSE, WE'LL BRING IT BACK FOR
QUESTIONS. SENATOR BECKER, I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR. I KNOW
YOU'RE VERY PASSIONATE ABOUT
THIS AND HAVE WORKED HARD ON
THIS, AND IT'S A CRITICAL ISSUE
IF WE'RE GOING TO HAVE FOLKS
TRANSITION TO EVS, THEY HAVE TO
HAVE RELIABLE CHARGING. MAYBE
YOU COULD. I'M JUST TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND MAKE SURE I
UNDERSTAND THE AMENDMENT S,
MAYBE YOU COULD MAYBE LET ME
JUST READ THEM SINCE THEY'RE
HERE, IF THAT'S OKAY.
AMENDMENTS. DELETE SECTION TWO
OF THE BILL. RECAST ROAMING
REQUIREMENTS TO CLARIFY THAT THE
PROSPECTIVE ROAMING REQUIREMENTS
THAT THE CEC ADOPTS PURSUANT TO
ITS EXISTING AUTHORITY, SHALL
ONLY APPLY TO MAJOR EV CHARGING
NETWORK OPERATORS, WHICH SHALL
BE DEFINED AS THOSE NETWORKS
THAT DO BOTH OF THE FOLLOWING.
NUMBER ONE. MAINTAIN A CUSTOMER
FACING WEB BASED APPLICATION.
NUMBER TWO OPERATE AT LEAST 100
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE CHARGERS
WITHIN CALIFORNIA. AUTHORIZED
THE CEC TO RAISE THE THRESHOLD
OF PUBLICLY AVAILABLE CHARGERS.
A NETWORK MUST OPERATE BEFORE
TRIGGERING ROAMING REQUIREMENTS,
AND YOU'VE AGREED TO TAKE THOSE
AMENDMENTS RIGHT? DID YOU WANT
TO FINISH YOUR. WELL, JUST YEAH.
WE LOVE YOUR TAKE ON THOSE,
AMENDMENTS. AND DOES IT STILL GO
BACK? DO THEY. SO THE PART THAT
WAS STRUCK WITH, IN, IN THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS IS THE PART
THAT GOES BACK TO DO THE
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THE CHARGERS
THAT, YOU KNOW, PREVIOUSLY WERE
INSTALLED. I WOULD STILL
EVENTUALLY LIKE TO SEE THOSE
WORK BETTER BECAUSE WE'VE ALL
HEARD THE HORROR STORIES, PEOPLE
GOING TO CHARGERS AND, GETTING
STUCK SOMEPLACE BECAUSE THE
CHARGERS DON'T WORK. BUT
SPECIFICALLY, THAT'S ALL OUT OF
THE BILL RIGHT NOW. RIGHT NOW
WE'RE JUST TALKING ABOUT ROAMING
AGREEMENTS. AND BECAUSE THE
LANGUAGE IS RELATIVELY NEW, WE
STILL HAVE SOME PEOPLE THAT HAVE
MOVED FROM SUPPORT TO OPPOSITION
. THÀNH WE HAVE ALREADY
DISCUSSED AMENDMENTS WITH THEM.
WE ARE COMPLETELY IN SUPPORT OF
THOSE AMENDMENTS AND ARE
PLANNING ON TAKING THEM IN
TRANSPORTATION. THÀNH GOT IT,
GOT IT. THAT WOULD AND AGAIN,
THE ROAMING AGREEMENT. SO I MEAN
THE MAJOR PART IS STILL THRUST
IS STILL AROUND THE KIND OF
UPTOWN UPTIME AND RELIABILITY
AND IT'S JUST THAT SO THAT THESE
, THESE CHARGERS WOULD BE
AVAILABLE ON APPS. SO YEAH IT'S
YOU KNOW BEING ABLE TO DO
BILLING AND IT'S AND IT'S, JUST
BEING ABLE TO, TO SEE WHAT
UPTIME IS. IT'S JUST IT'S
SHARING THE INFORMATION
BASICALLY TO REALLY CREATE MORE
OF A ECOSYSTEM, AROUND THESE EV
CHARGERS AS OPPOSED TO EACH
INDIVIDUAL CHARGER RUNNING ITS
OWN BUSINESS. GOOD, GOOD. WELL,
LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING THE
TOTALITY OF THE AMENDMENTS. BUT
I WILL BE SUPPORTING TODAY AND
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK ON THIS
ISSUE. SENATOR DURAZZO, YES,
JUST A QUESTION. IF YOU COULD
RESPOND, TO THE ISSUE OF THAT,
THE OPPOSITION WITNESS SPOKE OF
HOW HOW THIS COULD INTERFERE
WITH BUSINESS ABILITY TO COME UP
WITH THE BEST MODELS. YEAH WHAT
HE THEY THEY I THINK, IN
CONCEPT, ARE IN SUPPORT OF
ROAMING AGREEMENTS. THEY JUST
WANT GUARDRAILS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT, IT DOESN'T NEGATIVELY
AFFECT THEIR COMPANIES. AND WE
HAVE ALREADY DISCUSSED, LIKE I
SAID, THE LANGUAGE, THE
AMENDMENTS ARE, NEW. AND SO WE
ARE GOING TO TAKE ADDITIONAL
AMENDMENTS IN TRANSPORTATION,
THAT WILL, ALLEVIATE THE
CONCERNS THEY HAVE. OKAY. THANK
YOU. SENATOR RUBIO HANG ON.
RUBIO THEN. GROVE. YEAH. THANK
YOU. WELL FIRST OF ALL, I JUST
WANT TO SAY, I KNOW THIS IS A
VERY COMPLICATED, TOPIC IN THAT
IT SEEMS FAIRLY NEW. AND I KNOW
THAT, YOU KNOW, PEOPLE HAD
CONCERNS ABOUT THE RETROACTIVE
NESS AND OTHER THINGS, BUT I,
YOU KNOW, I HAVE TO COMMEND YOU
IF YOU DON'T START THE
CONVERSATION, IT DOESN'T HAPPEN.
AND I HAVE HEARD THE HORROR
STORIES AND SO I'M, YOU KNOW,
THANKFUL FOR THE OPPOSITION AND
YOU COMING TOGETHER BECAUSE WE
HAVE TO GET IT RIGHT. I MEAN,
THIS IS, YOU KNOW, WHERE WE'RE
HEADED, RIGHT? AND SO I REALLY
JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU FOR
BEING SO INNOVATIVE IN YOUR
THOUGHTS AND MOVING THIS
FORWARD, BECAUSE I THINK IT'S
NECESSARY. BUT, YOU KNOW, WITH
THE UNDERSTANDING THAT EVERYONE
COMES TOGETHER AT THE TABLE,
INCLUDING THE OPPOSITION, TO
MAKE SURE WE HAVE TO GET THIS
RIGHT. THIS IS JUST MY ONLY
THOUGHT THAT AND I THINK I HEARD
YOU SAY, RIGHT, THAT EVERYONE'S
SITTING DOWN AT THE TABLE AND,
AND I'M GLAD FOR THAT BECAUSE
WE'VE HAD A LOT OF CONCERNS. BUT
I THINK YOU'VE ADDRESSED ALL THE
CONCERNS THAT I ALSO HAD. SO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, SENATOR.
SENATOR GROVE, I TOO APPRECIATE
BECAUSE WE DO HEAR THE HORROR
STORIES OF BEING STRANDED,
CARRYING A GENERATOR ON THE BACK
OF YOUR CAR TO CHARGE YOUR
ELECTRIC VEHICLE. I'VE SEEN
PICTURES OF THAT. I MEAN, I HAVE
AND, YOU KNOW, IN THE MOUNTAIN
COMMUNITIES IN THE DISTRICT, SO
I REALIZE THAT THERE'S A
PROBLEM, I GUESS, MY THING ON
THE AGREEMENTS. IF IT DOES, I
MEAN, OBVIOUSLY THE OPPOSITION
DOESN'T THINK GOVERNMENT IS THE
BEST PERSON RESPONSIBLE FOR
MAKING BUSINESS TO BUSINESS
AGREEMENTS WITH OTHER BUSINESS.
YOU KNOW, I AND I AGREE 100. I
THINK BUSINESSES SHOULD BE
ALLOWED TO BE ABLE TO NEGOTIATE
AND DO WHAT'S BEST FOR THEIR
INDUSTRIES AND FOR THE CONSUMER.
AND I THINK MAKING A THE CEC OR
GOVERNMENT INVOLVED IN THAT IS,
IS, YOU KNOW, TELLING THEM THAT
THE GOVERNMENT KNOWS HOW TO PLAN
A BUSINESS ROAMING TO AND A
BUSINESS AGREEMENT VERSUS THE
BUSINESS THEMSELVES IS NOT
SOMETHING I WOULD SUPPORT. BUT
I, I APPRECIATE WHERE YOU'RE
GOING WITH THIS, BUT I ALSO HAVE
A QUESTION, YOU KNOW, WHEN YOU
TALK ABOUT THE ROAMING, DEVICES
OR THE ROAMING APPS AND THE
UPLOAD IN THE IMMEDIATE
TECHNOLOGY FOR THE RECORD
KEEPING, UPLOAD, RECORD KEEPING,
ARE THERE APPS OUT THERE FOR
THAT, OR DO THOSE APPS HAVE TO
BE, AND I'M TECHNOLOGY
CHALLENGED, YOU KNOW. SO ARE
THOSE ARE THERE APPS OUT THERE
CAN IMMEDIATELY BE APPLIED OR IS
THIS SOMETHING THAT HAS TO BE
DEVELOPED BY THE INDUSTRY,
FIRST, I WANT TO RESPOND TO YOUR
FIRST CONCERN ABOUT PRIVATE
BUSINESS. MOST OF THESE CHARGERS
HAVE BEEN PAID WITH PARTIALLY AT
LEAST, OR FULLY BY TAXPAYER
MONIES. AND SO I THINK IT IS
COMPLETELY WITHIN OUR PURVIEW
TO, HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE FOR
WORKING, SINCE IT'S, WE HAVE, AS
TAXPAYERS, SUPPORTED THEM. SO
THERE ARE ALREADY ROAMING
AGREEMENTS CGRTS BETWEEN
COMPANIES. SO THOSE APPS EXIST.
AND ROAMING AGREEMENTS IN SOME
WAYS ARE SIMILAR TO LIKE ATMS.
THEY USE ROAMING AGREEMENTS ALSO
SHARING INFORMATION, SHARING
INFORMATION. SO YOU CAN USE
OTHER BANKS ATMS. SO IT'S,
THAT'S ONE WAY TO REALLY LOOK AT
IT, IS THAT YOU ARE ABLE TO USE
THESE PUBLICLY AVAILABLE
CHARGERS WHEREVER YOU GO, BUT
YOU NEED TO HAVE THAT
INFORMATION SHARED. OKAY. I
APPRECIATE THAT, YOU JUST
SOLIDIFIED WHAT I SAID IN
AGRICULTURAL COMMUNITY ABOUT
SUBSIDIZATION. WE PASSED POLICY
THAT REGULATES SOMETHING, THAT
MANDATES SOMETHING, AND THEN WE
HAVE TO SUBSIDIZE IT TO MAKE IT
WORK. AND THEN WE GO BACK AFTER
AND FOR MAKING A PROFIT AND
MAKING IT WORK. IT'S JUST IT'S
JUST THE SYSTEM, THE WHOLE
SYSTEM OF THE CALIFORNIA
GOVERNMENT AND HOW WE OPERATE
HERE. BUT, I GET WHERE YOU'RE
TRYING TO GO. I DO HAVE
CONSTITUENTS THAT DRIVE EVS IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY, AND THEY ARE
CONCERNED. I HAD SOMEBODY COMING
FROM SACRAMENTO TO MEET WITH A
GROUP OF INDIVIDUALS, FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION, AND I'M LIKE,
HEY, YOU'RE LATE, YOU'RE LATE.
AND I WAS CALLING HIM. HE HAD TO
STOP IN FRESNO AND CHARGE HIS
CAR FOR TWO HOURS BECAUSE THERE
WASN'T A CHARGING STATION
BETWEEN, YOU KNOW, THAT HE HAD
ACCESS TO. SO I GET IT. I GET
THAT EV USERS NEED TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE A CHARGING STATION. IT
NEEDS TO HAVE CONNECTIVITY FROM
WHOEVER'S GOING TO PROVIDE THE
POWER, BECAUSE SOMETIMES THAT'S
THE ISSUE. THERE'S NO
CONNECTIVITY FROM THE IOUS. AND
SO I DO APPRECIATE YOU LIKE MY
COLLEAGUE SAID, STARTING THE
CONVERSATION, STARTING THE
CONVERSATION. BUT I DO HAVE A
REAL PROBLEM WITH THE BUSINESS
TO BUSINESS THING. BEING A
BUSINESS OWNER FOR 30 YEARS IN
THE STATE, I THINK THAT BUSINESS
MAKE BETTER DECISIONS THAN THE
STATE DOES MOST OF THE TIME. SO,
BUT I APPRECIATE YOU AT LEAST
STARTING CONVERSATION AND
LOOKING AT THIS. THANK YOU. OKAY
SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS ON MY
LIST, WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR CABALLERO. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE? RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR. I VOTE. OKAY. THE
MOTION IS Dð PASS TO
TRANSPORTATION ON WITH THE
AMENDMENTS. AND YOU ARE TAKING
THE AMENDMENTS. CORRECT YES.
OKAY. WOULD YOU CALL THE ROLL
OKAY. THE MOTION IS Dð PASS TO
BE AMENDED IN THE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE, BRADFORD. DALLY NOT
VOTING. DALLY NOT VOTING. ASHBY
ASHBY. AYE. BECKER. BECKER. AYE.
CABALLERO CABALLERO. AYE. DODD.
DODD. AYE. DURAZZO DURAZZO. AYE.
EGGMAN GONZALEZ. GROVE. GROVE.
NOT VOTING. LIMÓN. MIN. NEWMAN
RUBIO. RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO
CIERTO. NOT VOTING. SKINNER
STERN. WILK 6 TO 0 SIX ZERO.
WE'LL LEAVE THAT BILL ON CALL
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. THANK YOU.
SENATOR, WHAT HAPPENED TO
GALLAGHER? SEE OH MY GOD. YEAH.
WE COULD GO. OH, THERE HE IS.
THANK YOU, ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR
BEING SO COURTEOUS TO THE
ASSEMBLYWOMAN. BE MADE AWARE.
WELL, I TRIED TO, BECAUSE I NEED
ONE. ALWAYS HAPPY TO OBLIGE THE
GENTLELADY FROM THOUSAND OAKS.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. GOOD
MORNING. I'M HAPPY TO PRESENT,
THIS MAY BE YOUR GUYS'S LAST
BILL. I WANT TO END ON A
HOPEFULLY ON A, YOU KNOW, JUST A
DISTRICT NONCONNAH BILL, THAT,
THAT HOPEFULLY WE CAN, GET YOUR
SUPPORT FOR TODAY. SO AB, 2750,
IS REALLY FOCUSED ON THE RIO
BRAVO BIOMASS PLAN IN PLACER
COUNTY IN MY DISTRICT, AND I
THINK, AS MANY OF YOU KNOW, THE
VICE CHAIR AND I, YOU KNOW, HAVE
WORKED ON THESE ISSUES FOR MANY
YEARS, THESE BIOMASS PLANTS ARE
VERY IMPORTANT, ESPECIALLY TO
COMBATING WILDFIRE. YOU KNOW, A
LOT OF THE FUELS THAT WE'RE
TAKING OUT OF OUR FORESTS TO, TO
MAKE THEM HEALTHIER, TO MAKE
THEM MORE FIRE RESILIENT, YOU
KNOW, GO THROUGH THESE, THESE
PLANTS. SO IT'S A BIG DEAL WHEN
ONE OF THEM IS AFFECTED, SB
1109, YOU GUYS REMEMBER EXTENDED
BIRUM FOR ANOTHER FIVE YEARS,
ONE OF THE COMPONENTS OF THAT
LEGISLATION SAID THAT THEY HAVE
TO BE, OR THAT, THAT THEY DON'T
HAVE TO CONTRACT IF THEY'RE IN
SEVERE EXTREME NON-ATTAINMENT
AREAS, FOR AIR QUALITY. NOW I
WANT TO BE VERY CLEAR. THE RIO
BRAVO PLANT ACTUALLY IS IN
ATTAINMENT. WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
ACTUAL EMISSIONS, AND THE
MEASUREMENTS OF THE EMISSIONS,
IT IS IN ATTAINMENT, THIS THIS
AREA DOES NOT EXCEED AND, AND
GET INTO THE SEVERE EXTREME BUT
THE REGIONAL AIR QUALITY BOARD
PUT THEMSELVES IN NONATTAINMENT
VOLUNTARILY, FOR REASONS THAT
DON'T HAVE ANYTHING TO DO WITH
EMISSIONS. IT'S MORE ABOUT
GETTING ADDITIONAL TIME, TO MEET
OTHER REQUIREMENTS, REGULATORY
REQUIREMENTS. SO THEY PUT
THEMSELVES VOLUNTARILY INTO THAT
ZONE. IT'S NOT BECAUSE OF
EMISSIONS. AND I THINK THAT'S
THE KEY POINT HERE, IS THAT RIO
BRAVO OBVIOUSLY WOULD STILL LIKE
TO BE QUALIFIED FOR THE BOWERHAM
PROGRAM AND HAVE CONTRACTS,
GOING FORWARD. BUT BECAUSE, OF
THE REGIONAL BOARD PUTTING
THEMSELVES IN NONATTAINMENT,
THAT IS AT RISK. AND SO THIS
BILL WOULD SIMPLY JUST CLARIFY
IF YOU'RE, IF THE AIR DISTRICT
VOLUNTARILY PUT THEMSELVES INTO,
YOU KNOW, THE NONATTAINMENT THAT
THAT WOULDN'T AFFECT THEIR
ELIGIBILITY. YOU KNOW, FOR
GETTING THE BOWERHAM CONTRACT
EXTENSIONS UNDER, 1109, SO, YOU
KNOW, AGAIN, I MEAN, THIS THIS
IS AN IMPORTANT, IMPORTANT PLANT
IN OUR DISTRICT, IT TAKES 80% OF
ITS FEEDSTOCK FROM HIGH FIRE
HAZARD AND VERY HIGH FIRE HAZARD
SEVERITY ZONES IN THE
SURROUNDING COMMUNITY. AND THEY
SUPPORT 28 DIRECT EMPLOYEES AND
HUNDREDS OF INDIRECT CONTRACTORS
THAT ARE ASSOCIATED WITH RIO
BRAVO, ALSO, YOU KNOW, IN THE AG
SECTOR, I MEAN, WE HAVE LESS AND
LESS ABILITY TO, YOU KNOW, FOR
WHEN WE TAKE OUT AN ORCHARD OR
WHEN WE HAVE, YOU KNOW,
BYPRODUCTS FROM AGRICULTURE TO,
TO, TO TAKE THEM TO A BIOMASS
FACILITY WHERE THEY CAN BE
BURNED. AND IT'S ACTUALLY MUCH
LESS EMISSION. OUR OTHER
ALTERNATIVE IS TO OPEN, BURN
THEM, YOU KNOW, WHICH IS
ACTUALLY GOING TO BE NOT AS GOOD
OF A SITUATION FROM EMISSIONS
STANDPOINT. SO, I HOPE THAT WE
CAN GET YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS. I
DO HAVE WITH US, TWO WITNESSES,
ERIC WHITE, WITH THE PLACER
COUNTY AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
DISTRICT, WHO CAN HELP GIVE SOME
MORE DETAILS ON WHAT EXACTLY
HAPPENED THERE. AND THEN JULIE
MALINOWSKI, BALL, WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BIOMASS ALLIANCE,
EACH OF YOUR WITNESSES. I HAVE
TWO MINUTES, THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIRMAN. AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS ERIC
WHITE, AND I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
THE PLACER COUNTY AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL DISTRICT. IT'S MY
PLEASURE TO BE HERE TODAY TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB 2750.
THIS IMPORTANT BILL WILL HELP
ENSURE THAT A REGIONALLY
CRITICAL BIOMASS PLANT WILL
REMAIN IN OPERATION FOR AT LEAST
AN ADDITIONAL FIVE YEARS,
PROVIDING AN IMPORTANT
DESTINATION FOR FOREST BIOMASS
AS GENERATED FROM THE STATE AND
FEDERAL FOREST REDUCTION AND
RESILIENCY OPERATIONS IN PLACER
COUNTY, FULLY ONE HALF OF THE
COUNTY IS FORESTED LANDS. IN
THIS LANDSCAPE, WE HAVE SEEN
SIGNIFICANT TREE MORTALITY FROM
INVASIVE BEETLES AND DROUGHT.
THIS HAS RESULTED IN SIGNIFICANT
SWATHS OF FORESTS THAT ARE
VULNERABLE TO WILDFIRE. AS WE AS
WAS SEEN LESS THAN TWO YEARS AGO
WITH THE MOSQUITO FIRE. TO
ADDRESS THIS, THERE IS A
SIGNIFICANT EFFORT UNDERFOOT TO
REDUCE WILDFIRE RISK THROUGH THE
LANDSCAPE, THROUGH LANDSCAPE
SCALE TREATMENT OF PUBLIC LANDS.
BUT WITH THIS WORK COMES THE
PRODUCTION OF LARGE QUANTITIES
OF FOREST BIOMASS WASTE AND
SLASH. HISTORICALLY, BECAUSE
THERE ARE NO VIABLE WOOD
UTILIZATION ALTERNATIVES, WE
HAVE SEEN THAT MUCH OF THIS
MATERIAL IS SIMPLY PILE BURNED
IN AN UNCONTROLLED FASHION IN
THE FOREST, RESULTING IN
SIGNIFICANT EMISSIONS OF OXIDES
OF NITROGEN AND PARTICULATE
MATTER. HOWEVER, BIOMASS
FACILITIES SUCH AS THE ONE
COVERED BY AB 2750 ARE EQUIPPED
WITH THE BEST AVAILABLE CONTROL
TECHNOLOGY. THROUGH THE USE OF
SUCH ADVANCED CONTROL
TECHNOLOGY, WE SEE THAT
EMISSIONS FROM SUCH FACILITIES
ARE SIGNIFICANTLY LESS WHEN
COMPARED AGAINST OPEN PILE
BURNING. A 99% REDUCTION IN
PARTICULATE MATTER EMISSIONS,
AND UP TO A 70% REDUCTION IN NOX
EMISSIONS. CURRENTLY, THE
FACILITY IN PLACER COUNTY THAT
IS COVERED BY AB 2750 RECEIVES
AT LEAST 80% OF ITS FEEDSTOCK
FROM HIGH HAZARD FOREST AREAS,
PREDOMINANTLY IN PLACER AND EL
DORADO COUNTIES. WITHOUT THIS
FACILITY, THIS IS MATERIAL THAT
WOULD OTHERWISE BE PILE BURNED
IN THE FOREST, WHICH WOULD
RESULT WHICH WOULD ACTUALLY
RESULT IN AN EMISSION INCREASE
FROM WHAT WE SEE TODAY.
ADDITIONALLY, ALTHOUGH THE
DISTRICT DOES NOT CURRENTLY MEET
FEDERAL AIR QUALITY STANDARDS,
OUR MODELING SHOWS THAT EVEN
WITH THE CONTINUED OPERATION OF
THIS FACILITY, THE DISTRICT IS
ON TRACK TO ATTAIN BOTH THE 2008
AND 2015 OZONE STANDARDS. IN
CLOSING, THE DISTRICT STRONGLY
SUPPORTS AB 2750 AS IT WILL HELP
ENSURE THAT A CRITICAL FOREST
BIOMASS UPTAKE FACILITY REMAINS
IN SERVICE. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU. NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU,
JULIE MALINOWSKI BALL, ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA BIOMASS ENERGY
ALLIANCE, I AM HERE TO REPORT
THAT THE BIRON PROGRAM IS
ACTUALLY FUNCTIONING EXACTLY HOW
THIS BODY ENVISIONED IT TO
FUNCTION. GOVERNOR BROWN
ACTUALLY ASKED THE PUC TO SET UP
THE PROGRAM, DESIGN THE PROGRAM,
BUT IT WAS THE CALIFORNIA STATE
LEGISLATURE THAT PUT ALL THE
BOOKENDS THAT THIS PROGRAM
NEEDED TO BE TO BE AS MOST
EFFICIENT AND TARGETED AS
POSSIBLE. SO THE FACILITIES,
INCLUDING THE FACILITY TARGETED
IN THIS BILL, IS TAKING THE
WASTE MATERIAL OUT OF THE FOREST
THAT NO ONE ELSE IS GOING TO
TAKE. IT'S THE HARDER TO GET.
IT'S THE MORE EXPENSIVE, BUT
IT'S THE MOST ENVIRONMENTALLY
BENEFICIAL MATERIAL TO REMOVE
FROM THE FOREST AND PUT TO A
BENEFICIAL REUSE PROJECT LIKE
BIOENERGY. SO THIS BILL MAKES
THE BIRON PROGRAM WHOLE. AND FOR
THAT REASON, THAT IS WHY WE ARE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AND ASK
FOR YOUR I VOTE. THANK YOU.
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
STATE YOUR NAME AND YOUR
ORGANIZATION. PLEASE GOOD
MORNING. JULIA HALL WITH THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES IN SUPPORT. ALSO
PROVIDING SUPPORT TODAY FOR THE
INDEPENDENT ENERGY PRODUCERS.
THANK YOU. MORNING, KEVIN
JOHNSTON, CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION, IN SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING, KATIE FALKENBORG,
GENERAL GENERAL MANAGER OF RIO
BRAVO, ROCKLIN, IN SUPPORT. NOW
LET'S MOVE TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. ARE THERE WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION? OKAY. SEEING
NONE, WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. ANY QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS ABOUT THE COMMITTEE?
SENATOR RUBIO, I WAS JUST GOING
TO SAY, YOU KNOW, IT'S DISTRICT
SPECIFIC, BUT THANK YOU FOR ALL
THE INFORMATION. I WAS GOING TO
MOVE THE BILL WHEN APPROPRIATE.
THANK YOU. IT'S APPROPRIATE. I
WILL MOVE THE BILL. THANK YOU.
VICE CHAIR. MR. CHAIRMAN, I
APOLOGIZE FOR NOT WEARING A TIE
TO YOUR COMMITTEE, YEAH. YOU'RE
LUCKY IF YOU GET OUT. I'M TRYING
TO REMEDY THAT HERE, ACTUALLY,
IN REAL TIME. THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD. I
JUST WANT TO REAL QUICK. I HAVE
BIOMASS PLANTS IN MY DISTRICT,
WHICH YOU JUST SAW YESTERDAY ON
SOCIAL MEDIA. THE FIRES THAT
BROKE OUT. YOU LOOK AT ALL THOSE
EMISSIONS GOING OUT WHEN YOU
TAKE THAT FUEL AND PUT IT INTO A
POWER PLANT, MAKE GREEN ENERGY,
REDUCE THE NOX AND EMISSIONS BY
72, 97. MAKES GOOD SENSE. HAPPY
TO SUPPORT THE BILL. SENATOR
BACKER. THANK YOU. JUST TO
CLARIFY, SO THE LOCAL AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT HAD
VOLUNTEER HAD HAD VOLUNTARILY
ASKED TO BE RECLASSIFIED, IS
THAT THE REGIONAL ONE? YEAH. SO
PLACER IS PART OF A REGIONAL,
AIR QUALITY DISTRICT. AND THE
REGIONAL ONE VOLUNTARILY
RECLASSIFIED THEMSELVES. YES.
YEAH. AND LEADS TO THIS. YEAH.
OKAY. THANK YOU. SENATOR
CABALLERO. I LOVE THIS BILL.
I'LL BE VOTING YES TODAY. THANK
YOU SENATOR. ALL RIGHT. ANY
FURTHER QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS? I
TOO WANT TO JUST ADD MY SUPPORT.
IT'S A COMMON SENSE MEASURE. I
WOULD HOPE THAT MY COLLEAGUES
WHO HAVE NOT HAD A CHANCE TO
VISIT YOUR AREA, UNDERSTAND THAT
WE HAVE THESE FACILITIES HERE,
MANY OF THEM SITTING IDLE,
BECAUSE WE CHOOSE TO IGNORE THE
FACT THAT THEY ARE RELIABLE,
THEY'RE DISPATCHABLE, THEY'RE,
IN MANY WAYS RENEWABLE AS WELL.
WE HAVE THE FEEDSTOCK THERE AND
IT'S BEING ABLE TO UTILIZE IT.
SO I APPRECIATE YOUR EFFORT HERE
IN THIS SPACE. AND I WOULD LIKE
TO CLOSE GO RIGHT AHEAD, THANK
YOU, SENATOR. AND, YEAH, I'M
INFORMED THAT MY TIE HAS JUST
ARRIVED, SO, I DID TRY TO
RECTIFY THAT, ANYWAYS, THANK YOU
FOR YOUR FOR YOUR SUPPORT. AND
SENATORS, YOU KNOW, SEVERAL HERE
WHO HAVE BEEN VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
THESE MEASURES AND HELPING TO
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE THIS, YOU
KNOW, NEEDED TOOL, SO, THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU. CAN WE
HAVE HIM PUT ON HIS TIE BEFORE
WE VOTE? OH, IS THAT RIGHT?
OKAY. AS LONG AS THAT'S. IS THAT
FROM BERNIE OROZCO? IS THAT ONE
OF HIS TIES? OKAY. THIS IS EVEN
ONE THAT'S GOT DUCKS ON IT. OKAY
ALL RIGHT. MALLARD. MALLARD
DUCKS ON IT. SO IT'S VERY
APPROPRIATE, WE HAVE WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR RUBIO. WE HAVE
A Dð PASS TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE. DALLY. DALLY. AYE.
ASHBY. ASHBY AYE. BECKER. AYE.
BECKER. AYE. CABALLERO.
CABALLERO. AYE DODD. DURAZZO.
DURAZZO. AYE DODD. AYE. EGGMAN
GONZALEZ. GROVE. LIMÓN MIN.
NEWMAN. RUBIO RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO
SATO. AYE. SKINNER SKINNER. AYE.
STERN. WILK GROVE. AYE 11. 11 TO
0. OKAY. THAT MEASURE HAS 11
VOTES. YOU JUST GOT OUT BY THE
SKIN OF YOUR TIE, I WILL LEAVE
THE ROLL OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
TO ADD ON, SO. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. HE'S ON HIS WAY.
OKAY. YEAH. THE LAST. MEMBER SAT
ON. WE'LL START WITH. OKAY GO
THROUGH IT ANYWAY. YOU MADE US
WAIT. OUR LAST ITEM IS
ASSEMBLYMAN ZUBIATE, WHO HAS
GRACED US WITH HIS PRESENCE. AND
HE'S PRESENTING AB 3006 SECOND
COMING OF THE. WHEN YOU'RE
READY, YOU MAY BEGIN. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS, I'M PROUD TO
PRESENT AB 3006, WHICH PROMOTES
COLLABORATION AND THOUGHTFUL
PLANNING OF THE STATE'S OFFSHORE
WIND ECONOMY. CALIF HAS SOME OF
THE BEST OFFSHORE WIND RESOURCES
IN THE COUNTRY THAT CAN PROVIDE
CLEAN ENERGY AS THE SUN SETS,
AND WILL BE CRITICAL TO THE
STATE'S ABILITY TO MEET ITS
CLEAN ENERGY GOALS. OFFSHORE
WIND ALSO HAS THE POTENTIAL TO
BRING A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF
HIGH PAYING JOBS TO THE STATE,
ESPECIALLY IN COMMUNITIES
SURROUNDING THE STATE'S PORTS
AND SHIPPING HUBS. HOWEVER, THE
SHEER SCALE AND SIZE OF THE
TECHNOLOGY MEANS THAT THE STATE
WILL NEED TO BUILD SPECIALIZED
PORT FACILITIES IN A VERY SHORT
AMOUNT OF TIME. THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION AND ITS DRAFT
AB 525 OFFSHORE WIND STRATEGY
PLAN ESTIMATED THAT BETWEEN 11
AND $12 BILLION IS NEEDED TO
UPGRADE EXISTING PORT
INFRASTRUCTURE, AND IN FACT,
THAT NUMBER, HAS BEEN MODIFIED
RECENTLY TO BE AT LEAST $12
BILLION WITH THOROUGH PLANNING
AND TIMELINE ACCOUNTABILITY,
CALIFORNIA CAN BUILD THESE
DEVELOPMENTS IN A WAY THAT
SUPPORTS A ROBUST OFFSHORE WIND
ECONOMY IN THE STATE AND CREATES
VALUABLE MANUFACTURER AND
ASSEMBLY JOBS FOR MANY
CALIFORNIANS. AB 3006
PRIORITIZES PLANNING FOR
OFFSHORE WIND DEVELOPMENT BY
INCLUDING AN EVALUATION OF
FUNDING NEEDS FOR OFFSHORE WIND
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE GOVERNOR'S
FIVE YEAR INFRASTRUCTURE PLAN.
THIS BILL WILL HELP ENSURE THAT
THE INDUSTRY IS READY AND FUNDED
TO MEET OUR CLEAN ENERGY GOALS,
DESPITE ONGOING BUDGET
CONSTRAINTS. WITH ME TODAY IS
BRIAN WHITE, REPRESENTING
OFFSHORE WIND CALIFORNIA, THE
SPONSOR OF THE BILL, TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION AND
ASSIST WITH QUESTIONS. MR.
WHITE, YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. BRIAN
WHITE, ON BEHALF OF OFFSHORE
WIND, CALIFORNIA, WE ARE THE
SPONSORS OF AB 3006 AND WE
REPRESENT TECHNOLOGY COMPANIES,
DEVELOPERS, PORT REPRESENTATIVES
AND OTHERS WHO ARE IN THE
SUPPORT CATEGORY OF RESPONSIBLE
DEVELOPMENT OF FLOATING OFFSHORE
WIND. WE KNOW FROM VARIOUS STATE
AGENCY REPORTS THAT OFFSHORE
WIND WILL BECOME A CRITICAL
RESOURCE IN THE STATE'S ABILITY
TO MEET OUR OUR RENEWABLE ENERGY
GOALS BY 2045, AND IT WILL HELP
ADDRESS STATE'S GRID RELIABILITY
ISSUES AND ALSO RESULT IN
THOUSANDS OF FAMILY WAGE JOBS.
WITH THE ENACTMENT OF THE AB 525
THREE YEARS AGO, AND NOW WITH
THE CENTRAL PROCUREMENT BILL
THAT PASSED LAST YEAR, WITH
MEMBER GARCIA'S SUPPORT AND THE
ADMINISTRATION SUPPORT RIGHT
NOW, THE MOST CRITICAL ISSUE WE
NEED TO FACE IS HOW ARE WE GOING
TO GET THESE PROJECTS BUILT? AND
THAT IS THROUGH OFFSHORE WIND
PLANNING FOR PORTS. RIGHT NOW,
THE MOST IMMEDIATE CONCERN IS
FUNDING FOR PORTS. AND AS NOTED
BY SOME MEMBERS OF BR, THERE IS
GOING TO TAKE SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNTS OF FUNDING TO GET THESE
THINGS BUILT. CÁC NOTED THAT AT
LEAST $12 BILLION WILL BE NEEDED
FOR INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS. WHAT
WE NEED TO HAVE RIGHT NOW IS AN
IMMEDIATE DISCUSSION ABOUT
SIMPLY REQUIRING HOW DOES
OFFSHORE WIND FIT INTO LARGER
INFRASTRUCTURE PLANNING PROCESS,
AS THE GOVERNOR DOES A FIVE YEAR
PLANNING PROCESS EVERY FIVE
YEARS THROUGH THE BUDGET? ALL
WE'RE SIMPLY TRYING TO DO IS
INCLUDE PORT INFRASTRUCTURE
PLANNING. IN THAT FIVE YEAR
PLANNING PROCESS, AND THAT WILL
HAVE US GET READY FOR THESE HUGE
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS THAT ARE
GOING TO TAKE MASSIVE AMOUNTS OF
INFRASTRUCTURE TO BE BUILT. WE
KNOW THERE ARE PRIVATE FINANCING
AND AS WELL AS LOCAL FINANCING
AND FEDERAL FINANCING THAT WILL
BE PART OF THIS DISCUSSION. BUT
THE STATE NEEDS TO TAKE THE
LEAD. AND AT THE END OF THE DAY,
FAILURE TO PLAN FOR THESE
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS WILL
BECOME ULTIMATELY A PLAN FOR
FAILURE. IF WE DON'T GET THEM
STARTED RIGHT NOW. AND WITH
THAT, WE APPRECIATE SOME MEMBERS
OF LEADERSHIP IN THIS EFFORT AND
WE ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE, PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
AND YOUR ORGANIZATION. MARTIN
VENDIOLA, ON BEHALF OF THE
COALITION OF CALIFORNIA UTILITY
EMPLOYEES AND THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS AND SUPPORT. DAN TORO,
ON BEHALF OF THE PORT OF LONG
BEACH, STRONG SUPPORT. JORDAN
KERLEY ON BEHALF OF AMERICAN
CLEAN POWER CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING,
JACQUELINE MOORE AT THE PACIFIC
MERCHANT SHIPPING ASSOCIATION
HERE IN FULL SUPPORT. MELISSA
CORTEZ, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA WIND ENERGY
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT.
ALEJANDRO SOLIS, ON BEHALF OF
THE CLEAN POWER CAMPAIGN IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
NOW LET'S MOVE TO WITNESSES AND
OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHT. SEEING
NONE HERE IN THE ROOM, WE'LL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
ANY QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS, ON
THIS MEASURE, BILL, IT'S BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR BECKER. WE.
WHAT DO WE HAVE HERE? WE HAVE. A
DO PASS THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS.
OKAY. WE HAVE A MOTION BY BECKER
, WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE,
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR. AYE.
VOTE. OKAY. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON FILE ITEM TEN,
AB 3006. BRADFORD I BRADFORD I
DALLI. DALLI NÓ ASHBY I ASHBY.
AYE. BECKER. BECKER I CABALLERO.
CABALLERO I. DODD. DODD I
DURAZZO. DURAZZO I. EGGMAN.
GONZALEZ GROVE. GROVE NOT
VOTING. LIMÓN LIMON I MIN MIN I
NEWMAN. RUBIO. RUBIO I SATO.
SATO. NO. SKINNER SKINNER I
STERN. WILK 10 TO 2. THAT
MEASURE HAS 10 TO 2. WE'LL LEAVE
THE ROLL OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
. THANK YOU, ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
NOW MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING TO OPEN
A ROLL. WE'RE GOING TO START.
START AT THE TOP OF THE FILE
AND, ALLOW THOSE ABSENT MEMBERS
TO ADD ON. WE'LL START. WE'LL
FILE FILE ITEM ONE, AB 1921.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
PRESENT CURRENT VOTE EIGHT ZERO.
BOTH. CHAIR. VICE CHAIR. VOTING.
AYE ASHBY. ASHBY. AYE. DODD I
DODD I EGGMAN. EGGMAN I GONZALEZ
. LIMÓN. LEMON I MIN I MIN I
RUBIO RUBIO I CIERTO CIERTO. NOT
VOTING. STERN WILK 14 TO 0. 14
TO 0. ALL RIGHT, MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM TWO AB 2008 THREE BY
BERMAN. CURRENT VOTE SEVEN ONE.
CHAIR. VOTING AYE. VICE CHAIR
VOTING NO. DODD. Ã. DODD. AYE.
GONZALEZ GROVE. GROVE. NO. LEMON
LEMON I MIN MIN I RUBIO. RUBIO I
CIERTO. CIERTO NO. SKINNER.
SKINNER I STERN. WILK 12 TO 3.
ALL RIGHT. THE CURRENT MEASURES
12 TO 3 WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN. MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM 320
109. CURRENT VOTE FIVE ZERO.
CHAIR VOTING AYE. DALLI ASHBY.
AYE. ASHBY. AYE. DODD. VÌ DODD.
AYE. EGGMAN. EGGMAN. AYE.
GONZALEZ LEMON. LEMON I MIN MIN
I RUBIO. RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO.
NAVARRO CIERTO. NOT VOTING.
SKINNER I SKINNER. AYE. STERN
WILK 12 TO 0. CURRENT VOTES 12
TO 0 WILL LEAVE THE WORLD OPEN.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM FOUR AB
2462. BLESS YOU. CURRENT VOTE
FIVE ZERO. VICE CHAIR VOTING
AYE. BRADFORD I BRADFORD. AYE.
ASHBY I ASHBY. AYE. DODD I DODD
I EGGMAN. EGGMAN I GONZALEZ.
GROVE I GROVE AYE. LEMON, LEMON
I MIN MIN I RUBIO RUBIO I SATO I
SATO I SKINNER I SKINNER I
STERN. SORRY 2462 A MEMBER STERN
I WILK 2109 16 TO 0 I. ALL
RIGHT. WHAT'S GOING ON? 16 TO 0,
16 TO 0. OKAY, NOW MOVING ON TO
ITEM FIVE. AB 2697. CURRENT VOTE
SIX ZERO. VICE CHAIR NOT VOTING
BRADFORD. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
EGGMAN EGGMAN. AYE. GONZALEZ
LIMÓN. LEMON. AYE. MIN MIN. AYE.
NEWMAN A. NEWMAN. AYE. CIERTO
SORRY. SKINNER AYE. SKINNER.
AYE. STERN. A STERN. AYE WILK 13
ZERO 15 ZERO. NOW MOVING ON TO
FALL. ITEM SIX AB 2750. CURRENT
VOTE 11 ZERO. VICE CHAIR AND
CHAIR VOTING AYE. EGGMAN.
EGGMAN. AYE. GONZALEZ LIMON.
MIN. MIN AYE. NEWMAN NEWMAN.
AYE. STERN WILK. 14 TO 0. 14
ZERO. WE'LL LEAVE THE ROLL OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. MOVING ON TO
FALL. ITEM SEVEN AB 2765.
CURRENT VOTE SIX ZERO. CHAIR
VOTING AYE. DALLY. SEVEN.
FOLLOWING SEVEN 2765 BY
ASSEMBLY. PELLERIN ASHBY. AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. DODD AYE. DODD. AYE.
EGGMAN EGGMAN. AYE. GONZALEZ
LEMON. LEMON I MIN I MIN I
RUBIO. RUBIO I CIERTO CIERTO I
SKINNER. SKINNER. AYE. STERN A
STERN. AYE. WILK PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBER ON THIS MEASURE
ONE MORE TIME. DALLY GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ. AYE WILK 16 TO 0 16
ZERO. RIGHT MOVING ON TO FALL.
ITEM EIGHT AB 2780. CURRENT VOTE
SIX ZERO. CHAIR VOTING AYE. VICE
CHAIR. NOT VOTING DODD. AYE
DODD. AYE. GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ
AYE. LEMON. LEMON I MIN MIN AYE.
NEWMAN. NEWMAN AYE. RUBIO.
CIERTO SATO. NO. SKINNER
SKINNER. AYE. STERN. STERN. AYE
WILK. 13 TO 1. 13. WHAT? 113 TO
1. WE'LL LEAVE THE ROLL OPEN ONE
MORE TIME FOR THAT MEASURE. AND
NOW MOVING ON TO FALL ITEM NINE,
WHICH IS A CONSENT. AND FILE
ITEM 11, WHICH IS OUR CONSENT.
ON CONSENT, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR, ASHBY.
ASHBY. AYE. DODD. AYE. DODD.
AYE. EGGMAN EGGMAN. AYE.
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ. AYE LEMON.
LEMON I MEAN, I MIN I RUBIO.
RUBIO. AYE. SATO SATO. AYE.
SKINNER SKINNER. AYE. STERN A
STERN AYE. WILK WILK. WILK. ON
CONSENT. AYE WILK. AYE. SO. 1818
TO 0 18 ZERO CONSENT IS OUT. AND
OUR FINAL MEASURE FILE ITEM TEN
AB 3006, PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. CURRENT VOTE TEN TWO.
CHAIR. VOTING AYE. VICE CHAIR.
VOTING NO. EGGMAN. EGGMAN AYE.
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ. AYE NEWMAN.
NEWMAN. AYE STERN A STERN AYE.
WILK WILK. AYE OOPS. 15 TO 2.
THAT MEASURES 15 TO 2 IS OUT.
ALL RIGHT, MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING
TO GO THROUGH THE ROLL ONE LAST
TIME FOR THOSE ABSENT MEMBERS.
AND WE'RE GOING TO CLOSE THE
ROLL ON THOSE ITEMS AS WE CALL
THEM. SO BACK UP TO THE TOP OF
THE AGENDA FILE ITEM ONE 1921
CURRENT VOTE 14 ZERO GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ. AYE. SATO. OH, SORRY.
NEVER MIND. STERN A STERN I WILK
I WILK I 17 ZERO 17 ZERO. THAT
MEASURES OUT FILE ITEM TWO 2083
CURRENT VOTE 12 TO 3. GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ. AYE STERN A STERN AYE.
WILK AYE. WILK. AYE 15 315
THREE. THAT MEASURES OUT. FILE
ITEM THREE 2109. CURRENT VOTE 12
ZERO. DALLY GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ.
AYE STERN. AYE. STERN. AYE.
WILK. NOT VOTING. WILK. NOT
VOTING 14 ZERO 14 ZERO. THAT
MEASURES OUT NOW. MOVING ON TO
FILING FOR 2462 62. CURRENT VOTE
16 ZERO. GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ AYE.
WILK. AYE. WILK. AYE 18 ZERO.
THAT MEASURE IS OUT. FILE ITEM
FIVE 2697 CURRENT VOTE 16 OR I'M
SORRY, 13 ZERO. GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ AYE. WILK NOT VOTING.
WILK. NOT VOTING 14 ZERO 14
ZERO. THAT MEASURE IS OUT NOW.
AB 2750 FOLLOWING THEM SIX.
CURRENT VOTE 14 ZERO. GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ NOT VOTING LIMÓN. STERN
WILK. AYE. WILK AYE 15 ZERO 15
ZERO. THAT MEASURE IS OUT. NOW.
VOLUME SEVEN 2765. CURRENT VOTE
16 ZERO. DALLY WILK. AYE. WILK.
AYE 17 ZERO 17 ZERO. THAT
MEASURES OUT. NEXT UP, FOLLOWING
FILE ITEM EIGHT 2780. CURRENT
VOTE 13 ONE. RUBIO. RUBIO. AYE.
WILK NOT VOTING. WILK. NOT
VOTING 14 TO 1. 14 TO 1. THAT
MEASURE IS OUT. NOW FILE ITEM. I
MEAN, WE DID CONSENT, RIGHT?
EVERYBODY'S UP ON CONSENT. AND
LAST ONE IS FILE ITEM TEN
ZUBIATE 33,000 OH SIX. CURRENT
VOTE 15 TÍNH TWO. I THINK
EVERYBODY VOTED OR NOT.
EVERYBODY'S UP. OKAY MEMBERS,
THAT CONCLUDES OUR BUSINESS FOR
TODAY. AND THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON ENERGY UTILITIES AND
COMMUNICATIONS. IF YOU WEREN'T
ABLE TO, LEND YOUR VOICE OR
TESTIFY TODAY, PLEASE SUBMIT A
WRITING OR AN EMAIL TO ANY
CONCERNS TO THE COMMITTEE, AND
WE'LL BE HAPPY TO OBLIGE YOU.
MEMBERS, WE STAND ADJOURNED.